foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
might check ladies and gentlemen
people of the internet
as we get settled in
get settled in for another
evening and or morning depending on
where you are in the world
of Hogwarts Legacy and general video
game
conversation
why but it feels like longer than normal
since we did our our last stream but it
wasn't
oh it's just I think it's because
there's so much happening man there's
just it's like
the fact that we're this close now
things about to get real you guys
they're about about to get real really
fast
yeah I was like I was thinking wait did
I stream last week I did I actually
streamed
we did some streams over on Twitch as
well so we did multiple streams
but it feels like longer than normal
foreign
oh you know what else I just realized
we're gonna have to change the uh
we're gonna have to change the intro
once the game comes out man I'll have to
get some new stuff on there
welcome ladies and Gentlemen people of
the internet retro racket tour here I'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell this is a weekly live
show
where we talk all things Hogwarts Legacy
and other random shenanigans
other random Shenanigans wherever the
chat may lead us which often goes to
some interesting places let me tell you
so let's see we already had uh Jeremiah
Robertson renewing their membership
right when we got started tonight thank
you Jeremiah for being a member of House
Dragon tour and look at this guys now we
got the hammer
we got the hammer here nice and close
welcome to how Shrek and tour my friend
or welcome back see I'm always confused
the the little thing that I see it says
Jeremiah renewed their membership for
one month
so I'm like wait if they renewed it
wouldn't it be the second month if it's
a renewal
so whether it's number one or number two
Jeremiah thank you very much my friend
we also had uh per Barthel with a super
chat 10 super chat thank you so much per
bar so I don't see a message with it
so thank you for the kind uh the very
generous support there
and then oh oh hold on I think wait
Dustin I think you Dustin you beat Elwyn
you beat her by hold on make sure my
Math's right you beat her by eight
seconds
by eight
seconds you beat her
it was very very close let me tell you
very close uh Dustin with the five
dollar Super Chat Dustin says in before
the L1 membership gift in three streams
left
Dustin was indeed before Ellen but not
much before Elwyn with the five gifted
memberships Tom Russ Templar gaming
Michael Sullivan and Brittany L all
getting one of those gave the
memberships and guys
um yep yep Luna's here she's arrived
[Music]
you've probably heard my voice carrying
through the house and thought oh oh he's
streaming it's time
he's live he is streaming and we are
officially on
man all these memberships I need to
check again and see if we've unlocked
any more uh
I bet we have man I bet we've unlocked a
couple more
emo slots how are you so guys whenever
you have uh an e an email whenever you
have a membership
you get uh access to the emotes here on
the channel discount on merch a couple
of other things there's a uh extra
Community page special role over in the
Discord exclamation point Discord which
uh the Discord has really been growing
guys so if you want to have uh
a place to talk all things Hogwarts
Legacy among other people who are super
pumped about the game
I think it's going to get even crazier
obviously when the game comes out we
already have a
just when we they put out trailers this
was an idea we had I think two trailers
ago to do a
like an Excel sheet and then for
everybody to find when they find secrets
to put it in there so we were talking
with the mods today about we're going to
have like a whole section probably we
might just convert the spoiler section
to be to becoming
secrets and Easter eggs because you know
there's going to be so many you know
there's going to be so many so Elwyn
thank you so much for the gifteds guys
if you got one of those gifteds welcome
to Hal Shrek and tour you are now
officially one of our members
thank you very much uh Brittany renewed
their tier one membership as well that's
a two-month streak for Brittany or wait
then it also said Britney got yeah it's
like it's so weird sometimes it pops
them up separately I think Britney was
one of the gifteds
Templar gaming with the four months
thank you Templar gaming and then Russ
with the two months as a member here
member of House Dragon tour voltia you
guys man we we hadn't even gotten to the
intro to the to the welcoming of the
chat yet and you getting things started
like this man let's go everybody
everybody's feeling the hype the
excitement volte with the Super Chat a
retro sorry I missed some live streams
been dealing with life and my ex we all
know how that is oh sorry about that
volte
sorry to hear you're going through some
struggles right now hopefully everything
is going well with you yeah dude
everything's going great man
everything's uh
knock on
knockout wood because
when you have two kids it's like there's
always
especially now that school's back in
normally and everything we've had so
much sickness in our family of the past
like the past year really we've just
kind of like
rotated these different illnesses so I
actually wasn't feeling well at all last
week felt okay Tuesday then we did a
twitch stream
was it the next morning I think it was
the next morning I woke up feeling awful
like I did not think I was gonna be able
to stream power through
but yeah I mean other than that like
things are things are going pretty well
dude the Channel's doing great I'm
getting
obviously very excited for
what's happening in a month right
um it's just gonna be fun to see it all
come together
fun to see it all come together man
we're gonna be uh
so we're gonna I haven't finalized the
plans yet haven't officially finalized
but we I've decided we're definitely
going to be live streaming most likely
on Twitch for the gameplay
so I feel like most of you the night of
like midnight or whatever I feel like
most you're gonna be playing but if you
want to watch along we'll do it over on
Twitch but we're definitely gonna do
a super fun like epic countdown stream
counting down to midnight which I've
never I've never done anything like that
before so that should be that should be
interesting so we might have to get some
Jack box games going I don't know what
we'll do but that will be over here on
YouTube so
um let's see let me actually pull up the
calendar because
and this will of course be the seventh
because we want the Early Access
yeah so Monday
February the 6th is my is a Monday so
that Monday night we will for sure be
doing a live stream
on YouTube don't know the timing yet and
all that in terms of what time I'll be
going live but yeah we'll do a fun
countdown we'll probably look back at
some old videos old theories I think I
shared last time how Nico had the idea
of uh we should go back through some old
videos and I was like yeah let's go
through all of them
and it would just take an insane amount
of time just to watch though not even
comment on them I had no idea
I mean I knew we had a lot but I didn't
know it was that many
uh then Ravenclaw Tyrell gifting five
memberships as well Ravenclaw Tyrell
good to see here my friend and we are
welcoming I think that is five new brand
new members no way Stefan is two months
super Niche is two months wait are they
all too Nicholas is two months
okay so Tater is the that's the first
month for tater and L hubis first month
as well
thank you guys welcome
back to house wrecking Tour by the way
speaking of this Hammer man just be God
of War Ragnarok oh my gosh don't worry
I'm not gonna spoil it if you haven't
played it
so much I want to talk about with that
game
so much I want to talk about with that
game
there were there were quite a few
surprises I gotta say quite a few
surprises Jeremiah Robinson with a super
chat as well I'm a new member thanks for
the welcome hey Jeremiah good to have
you here my friend great great group of
people I think so anyway that you're
hanging out with right now
great group of people and it's just a
super fun Community to be a part of so
we're happy to have you uh like I said
the Discord exclamation point Discord if
you guys want to continue the
conversation when we're off stream
um but yeah we did a couple twitch
streams last week I the first one was
totally unannounced I mean I guess
technically it was announced but I
waited till right when I was going live
I was like I want to test some things
out make sure I still remember how to do
all this so I just announced it on
Twitter literally as we were going live
and I don't know like 35 40 of you
showed up
we had a good time over there then we
did it again the next day had even more
people but we're playing through Goblet
of Fire on the uh
the GameCube version but we're playing
it through Dolphin which works really
well with that version of the game makes
it look so nice unfortunately the game's
just not that great it's not very good
but uh I gotta figure out a time
probably honestly probably this week
we're probably gonna be doing a live
stream one or two on Twitch this week so
make sure in the Discord or follow me on
Twitter you can I'll make sure to let
you guys know what I'm doing I'll try to
give a little more notice then like hey
I'm going live but I definitely want to
try and finish that and I'd love to try
and play
man it's gonna be tough but I'd love to
try and play through five as well
because I know five is one of the
five kind of opens things back up you
have that open world again
um but yeah same name over on Twitch
retro record tour and then uh Sean
subscribe welcome Sean thank you for
subscribing
so thank you guys so much for the love
and support and then let's see what else
do we have here let's see everybody
that's hanging out in the chat right now
everybody hanging out in the chat in
case you're new here this is how we
start off the streams we go through we
see who's here we see who's hanging out
and we just give you guys a quick shout
out which
I still think this participants thing is
not totally accurate because it just
does there's way more of you in here
than what shows on this so I'm just
gonna go back to the chat I'm gonna go
through the chat here
Debbie welcome Debbie Robbins Stefan is
here I think Stefan
I saw your name on uh yeah you got one
of the gift it's nice so Stefan Dustin
Ravenclaw Tyrell Nicholas Olson all
members of house record tour right there
thank you guys for being here uh lost
the way don't usually make retro streams
because because of work but all of sick
today well Lily I'm so sorry to hear
that you're sick but
maybe this is a maybe this is a little
bright spot in your in your sickness so
glad you got to make it for a live
stream it is so cold in my house by the
way if you're wondering like yeah that's
why that's why we got the hand rubbing
going on here flame Boomerang welcome my
friend hit that like button uh Brittany
L Elwyn Tom
nagura Ravenclaw Christopher puff
welcome back Chris L who this all
members of house racket tool right there
uh Nokes I remember that name welcome
back Nokes Michael Sullivan Johnny the
hustle puff Russell here in the house
back-to-back members right there Timothy
ninja welcome back my friend Noisy Boy
Noob what's up Noob welcome back Noob
good to see you my friend Lauren D in
the house Ravenclaw Tyrell we already
said Ravenclaw Terrell but another shout
out there volte members of past records
were right there Debbie Robbins in the
house uh staffy politis I probably
completely botched that sorry about that
but welcome thank you for choosing to
spend your time here I know you guys
have a lot of options for live streams a
lot of ways to spend your time so
anytime at all that you hang out here or
watch any of my videos it's uh it's very
much appreciated
very much appreciated uh Brock member of
House wrecking tour laughingstock Jason
Hodges what is up my friend
what's happening in a month I know right
what what is it
what is it is there anything happening
in a month what is today January 10th
what's what's what could be happening
February 10th
February 7th for a lot of us here
that early access though
John Paul Johnson welcome my friend
welcome
uh let's see let's see anybody else
ether I'm late but I'm here hey we were
a little late getting started my son and
I
had to get a quick dub in fortnite
so that's why I was a little late
just a little bit late getting things
started here
Nico what's up Nico the real life Chief
warlock moderator here on the channel as
well
uh let's see Tater not playing at night
gonna play in the morning like four a.m
oh my goodness
yeah I'm just gonna play like
I don't know dude I took off work that
if I remember right I think it's a
Monday Tuesday Wednesday
so I'm gonna try to get some good sleep
during the day Monday
and then we'll just we'll see how far I
can go man we'll see how far we could
take it
like I said if you're just tuning in
we're gonna start Monday the 6th we'll
start the stream here
build up to midnight and then for those
of who want to watch gameplay we'll hop
over to Twitch and start which by the
way I was thinking about this in the car
on the way home today I was like wait a
second
I actually haven't pre-ordered it
digitally I don't have it pre-ordered
digitally
I've got a collector's edition
pre-ordered which is hard copy and then
I pre-ordered a hard copy of the deluxe
from Best Buy just honestly to kind of
have a backup
but I kept hoping we might get a review
copy or something a digital copy for
review
maybe yeah no haven't heard anything
hasn't happened yet we'll see we'll see
uh but yeah I guess I can always do that
tonight if I need to but I would want to
make sure I do the the preload so we're
ready to go right there at midnight
right there at midnight It's gotta be
ready to go
dark lord Aeron what's up my friend
we'll definitely be here for the
countdown then disappear from life and
reality for Assad
yeah it's gonna be fascinating dude but
I also feel like it's gonna be
I feel like there's gonna be a lot of
new people too just like in in our
community but just eyeballs on Hogwarts
in general a lot of new people
and some people love watching new games
at launch stream live so that's why
ultimately
decided to do it everything will be
brought over to YouTube though so don't
worry about that guys if you're if
you're like a YouTube only person
I've been testing out we started with
the Goblet of Fire
twitch stream that I did that's over on
YouTube the first one and the second
one's currently in editing but
I was talking to uh who was it Hogwarts
Legacy explained on Twitter so
apparently
he's done a lot of the gameplay streams
for the other games
and apparently from like the fourth one
on there are all kinds of copyright
issues with the music
which I hoped wouldn't happen until I
tried to do the Lego games because Lego
games have like the licensed music all
over them but it actually happened in
Goblet of Fire so the first video it
didn't pick up anything the second one
which I have uploaded
it flagged like two Jeremy Soule songs
which is weird because like the first
game was
those were Jeremy Soul as well and I
don't know copyright it's a weird thing
so I'm gonna have to see if we can't
like turn down the music in them I guess
which is kind of like a boring way to
play games but
gotta do what you gotta do on Twitch it
won't be a problem but because they just
go back and mute like the VOD
but on YouTube yeah I don't know we'll
have to figure something out let's
figure something out because I want to
keep doing them for sure
I want to keep doing them
uh Sally silly gookla gaming welcome
thank you for being here last my kin
Gemini King welcome Bristol boy let's
see did I I think I remember Bristol boy
member of House Records who are right
there Adam Hester God of War was off it
was so good dude it was so good I
enjoyed it so much
it started off a little slow for me but
I think it was because I
for those who follow the stream
regularly everything know that I
replayed the 2018 version of God of War
right before going in
and so I just got I got the platinum
trophy I got Kratos so powered up so
then when I went into the new one
I just felt so underpowered for a while
I don't feel like the runic attacks are
as strong in the second one but I may
just need to search out find one and
upgrade the right ones
um let's see what did I miss there we
just had a super chat from Megan sing
sometimes nice name Megan
thank you for being here hey retro I
took the week off work not taking any
chances I don't blame you sounds like a
good plan to me Megan a wizard Harry
sounds like a good plan and thank you
for the support on the stream here and
then a flurry of activity with a couple
new subscribers there hagrance thank you
for shouting out Haggard appreciate it
you're a wizard Harry
all right John Paul I think we said uh
jimin or wizard yummy jameen thank you
for being here Simeon uh Paula Paula
I like that Paula give me a little
pronunciation there in the name members
of house dragons were right there thank
you all for being here Dylan in the
house Dylan yes sir Dylan made it we got
Clint here Stephen Garrett is here
Let's see we already saw Noob uh we saw
Bristol boy we saw Knox I see CJ there
what's up CJ welcome thank you for being
here anna Silver Thread JP raven fire
paddyfoot is here in the house couple of
channel members there the lab athletic
my new favorite YouTuber what thank you
my friend what I'm looking forward to
most is wandering the castle grounds a
Forbidden Forest at night I feel this
will be the most hp-like experience at
least service level I hope so my friend
I hope so
I hope so
but yeah I think here are the kind words
I think I'm most looking forward to the
exploration too
I comment on one of Chandler's posts
today about
I just I just hope it's so full of
Easter eggs man and secrets like I hope
there are things
that are legitimately difficult to
unlock that like require
the community
to figure things out together Geek Squad
what's up D Squad yeah the chat just did
that thing where it jumped so it skipped
it skipped a bunch of you if I missed
any of you my apologies Nikki radar yo I
see you guys there Gabe Psalm Michael P
Mrs racketeur in the house how many
copies do you need Mrs record tour
I mean we could probably return one of
them but we gotta have a digital copy so
we can go live
1201 a.m you know it's very important
Stargazer Tim here as well Valyrian Sith
Lord
having surgery the Monday before release
spending all recovery playing Hogwarts
Legacy winning
oh Valerian Sith Lord I hope with hope
it's nothing too serious but
I mean that's a great way to spend
recovery a great way to spit in recovery
gotta say
inner fire gaming renewing their
membership
and it's not it's not a renewal
they became a member one month
but it says renewal either way you know
what inner fire gaming you are
officially a member
of house racketeur thanks so much for
being here
uh check out all those yeah all those
emotes you see people using the the
little uh welcome letter the Train the
house icons 48-hour stream oh no dark
lord Aaron I can't do that
cannot do that spill freak excited for
all the post launch coverage I know it's
gonna be crazy
it's gonna be so much
Olimar uh I had they haven't said
anything about Bogarts and and we also
haven't heard anything about ridiculous
so if it because if ridiculous was ever
confirmed
then you could just about say well of
course there's gonna be of course
they're gonna have the bogart then this
month about to be torture butter beer
please what's up another member of House
Records who are in the house
uh I need to get a girl
see all you guys are saying like
Chandler today was talking about how
this month's gonna go by so slow I'm
like really
because I feel overwhelmed of all like
all the stuff I was planning out videos
today thinking about all I still need to
get done before launch
It's Gonna Fly by for me I feel like
maybe that's a content creator thing
where we see all that we have to do
three or no five
five memberships from Stefan thank you
so much Stefan I was some it pops up it
says tier one we we only have one tier
so I don't think you guys are missing
out on anything it's all one tier right
now so let's see Stephan just gifted
five to Aryan d h wubby hey I recognize
that name wubby wubby's been here before
magic arachnid that's a cool name VP
non-japan welcome and pilot Joseph you
guys are all now officially members of
house raconteur thank you all so much
for being here hanging out tonight
yeah I want to play Jedi after uh
after Hogwarts and all that dies down I
think jedi'll be one of the first
alternate games you know we play for the
channel
but I need to play the first one which
just coincidentally it's free on
Playstation Plus right now
so that'll be a nice uh
that'll be a nice one for me to play I
might have time
ah no probably not before launch because
I want to try and get through as many of
the Potter games as I can before launch
all right
Fallen order is pretty good
Hogwarts will never die down I mean like
eventually eventually you guys will see
and do everything all the videos will
have been made
and then hopefully they're like here's
some uh DLC
hopefully that's what happens
at that point
but man you guys I mean today officially
so January 10th so we're one month away
from I guess that's what they're
considering the
the global or the the like the big
launch
which let's see here
let's see here my friends let's go ahead
and switch screens which by the way
thank you all again everybody who's here
hanging out appreciate you all choosing
to spend your time here uh if you're new
here we do this every Tuesday evening
and as Dustin reminded us earlier chat
we have so including tonight
including tonight we've got four streams
left
if we don't include tonight so if we
just start talking the 17th so we'll do
live stream the 17th live stream the
24th live stream the 31st then the next
stream would be the countdown stream I
mean we're single digit streams
we're we're counting on one hand the
number of streams we have left before
the launch Rave of claw Tyrell again
what is happening dude
Ravenclaw Tyrell dude thank you so much
five more gifted memberships Janet Ahmad
Talon Pete and
politis
politics politis welcome to Gryffindor
Ravenclaw Tyrell thank you so much dude
very much appreciated
another regular regular of the stream
here
all right let's go ahead and switch
screens you guys let's switch screens
and get into the news
let's get into the Hogwarts Legacy news
of which there's not a lot not a lot but
a fair amounts go over so this was the
Tweet Chandler posted today that I was
talking about one month I don't think
anyone can really prepare you for what
the launch of your first game feels like
immensely proud of the work everyone on
the team has put into this and the
weight for these final four weeks is
going to be tough see I'm like Chandler
dude I know you got a lot to do
maybe he's talking about maybe Chandler
I know they go back and watch streams so
Chandler maybe you're talking about the
community
maybe you're talking about us I know
it's Gonna Fly by for you
I I mean who knows like this is
one month to go right people are seeing
TV commercials we're seeing ads on
YouTube people are seeing commercials at
the cinema
I I mean I'll be honest with you guys I
haven't heard anything about like early
copies haven't heard anything I don't
know if they're doing like review
embargoes don't know
don't know maybe the bigger maybe like
you know IGN GameStop all those maybe
they're going to be doing reviews early
no idea
um
but you gotta think there's something
there's something else big planned right
you gotta think there's one more big
thing
so we shall see we shall see but yeah I
mean all the marketing that's gonna get
ratcheted up big time
uh you've seen all sorts of new videos
now I mean big big big YouTubers
starting to cover this game
um a lot more frequently
so yeah we've got a I was trying to
chart out today I was pulling up a
calendar and being like okay how many
videos do I have left before launch
because I gotta like whatever I want to
include whatever I want to talk about
before launch
I I mean I gotta decide man I gotta
decide now what are the what are the
final videos we're gonna make before we
know right before we know what happens
oh man
wait actually right oh yeah I mean
review situation for this game will be
particularly interesting particularly
interesting
Let's see we also had uh let's see
lowercase Logan lower case Logan what is
oh my friend with the Super Chat retro
do you think IGN will do a preview
series or will they avoid you to
backlash
I'd say IGN probably will yeah I mean
they did the um
they posted the footage of the showcases
so I would think so
but I have no idea like I've I've
officially stopped caring
about what
about what anybody else does really
about this game so
that's where I'm at I don't even know if
I'm gonna look at reviews at all I
honestly don't know
honestly don't know I certainly don't
care I do not care what
I mean I've said it on every live stream
I've been on uh like with podcasts now
and some of the other guys like I just
uh
I mean this game could literally launch
to 2 out of 10 scores and I'm I'm gonna
I mean I'm obviously gonna play it it
will all be sad together if that's if
that's what happens
but yeah I just I don't care I don't
care
I don't need I don't need any preview
footage I don't need any but we shall
see we shall see if they do it if any of
the bigger websites covered it and how
much they covered I think they will
it'll just be you know
there'll be lots of uh
hedging qualifying
oh and did you know this by the way but
yeah I I'm not gonna get into it not
gonna get into it
we very we've not this channel man is
for people who are excited about the
game who are looking forward to the game
who want to know more about the game
and once the game's out it'll be for
people who are wanting to talk about the
game
uh in in
the game right the game the g-a-m-e
so that's what we're gonna stay focused
on man
but yeah appreciate your support as
always Logan
lower case Logan my goodness I can't
speak
Mary studios here as well Mary thank you
for being here Susie Q
welcome Susie Q channel members right
there
ether you know
I have really changed my opinion on that
over the years
I really have because there was a time
when
I really did rely and I I mean if I mean
totally honest I still do to some extent
rely on review scores a little bit
but not a lot like I feel like the older
you get and you have less time to game
they can be somewhat helpful if you're
like
I just need to see you know I'm looking
for a new game and if there's not one
that you've identified like let's see
what's came out recently but honestly
now like
yeah I mean I'm I'm definitely leaning
more toward where you're at either of
being like
I mean I'll watch if it's one I'm like
on the fence on I'll watch people play
it
I'll watch a couple YouTube videos of
people maybe doing
more not necessarily reviews that are
like I'm gonna assign a score and give
it like all this see I used to man I
used to be so for like I thought review
scores are very valuable
but man I don't know anymore I don't
know it's just so easy to get
information from people you trust now
right
with the power of YouTube and twitch and
I mean I don't know people probably do
reviews on Tick Tock and stuff too right
it's like they're just so many ways you
you find those people you jive with and
you're like oh I this person like they
kind of have some similar gaming Styles
similar gaming taste that I do
and then you listen to them talk about
the game like that's what I do and then
you listen to the Nuance listen to the
pros and cons yeah so I get I guess I'm
talking myself into
I can't remember the last time I looked
it
let me see did I
usually I kind of know like
the more you are in the gaming industry
right and watching
Publishers and developers in the
industry you kind of know
you know who the Heavy Hitters are in
terms of like the devs
you know which ones are you're gonna buy
automatic like God of War I mean
I did not need to see a review score for
that but you most people probably didn't
you know because of the pedigree of the
studio you know how that game's gonna be
that's why Hogwarts could be a very
interesting one
because it is a studio that hasn't put
out a game in a long time and it's
completely different from anything
they've ever done
and it's also such a huge huge passion
project for them
one that they have clearly put so much
care and love into
yeah yeah we'll see man we'll see
forgot all about the winter ASMR Dustin
that's you're so right I forgot about it
too
that's another big one that is another
big one that they would need to uh I
think for sure we'll get that right
for sure we'll get that
uh Logan Paul again I still don't get it
how do you claim pre-order bonuses when
you buy physical uh so they just include
it in the um
in the box like a digital code
might cancel your pre-order and go
digital well like so I I pre-ordered um
like God of War the Collector's Edition
that's how we got
that's how we got this magnificent
magnificent piece right here
but um
there's a code in the Box
and it'll just have
a digital code that you put in and then
it'll give you whatever digital items
are included now the the interesting one
for physical is the 72 hours early
access
that's the interesting one
which actually I don't know have they
even
have they even confirmed yet if
if it will be going live at midnight
that shouldn't make all these plan like
for the Early Edition
you don't have to right
well you guys could probably see if
you've pre-ordered it digitally you can
probably see the countdown but yeah if
you pre-ordered the deluxe or
collector's physical
then it's all about your retailer man
like are you picking it up in store are
you having it shipped to you because
then that 72 hours then it becomes a big
question
yeah I don't see how the physical will
be at midnight unless
people do midnight launches but I have
no idea if companies are even doing that
anymore or not because it's so much
digital now
countdown time of the play yet yeah
because I don't guess you can pre-load
yet on Playstation either
PlayStation says February 6th at 12 a.m
well so I guess that'd be February 7th
well yeah because I think it's
officially it's like 1201. so yeah
that makes sense
have you noticed that there are two
separate intros about our character
getting sorted one with fig and the
other not yeah I think they changed that
Johnny so the one that um like this
little gift that I posted here
Actually I don't even know which one
that one's from but in the first
revealed trailer yeah and it's also a
different person putting the hat on
so in the in the first trailer it was
what we are pretty sure
is Headmaster black
whereas in the updated one it is uh
who we think is Professor Weasley
yeah Pacific Time Jenny you all get it
earlier well technically the same time
right but
at least you don't have to stay up till
midnight
February 6 12 a.m for the pre-download
gotcha Elwyn thank you for the
clarification yeah that makes sense then
so you can that gives you a full 24
hours to get it get it all set up
oh that's weird Bristol boy steam
Heisenberg white welcome did you notice
that you can't look through the windows
at Hogwarts is always the bright
sunlight Block in the view no matter how
close you are
I don't think I have noticed that no
Christian gamer what's up dude it's
going well going well hanging out
talking about all of the uh
let's also go to the um
they did do a post today
and uh
yesterday
yeah so they've been doing these little
posts like this
which I think we talked about this one
last week the incendio one and also
did someone say chicken one
and then they had this one about wig and
weld potion
restore your health so to make the Wagon
Wheel potion here's what you're gonna
need one drop of [ __ ] Clump juice
one batch of dittany leaves
and then you get one bottle of William
potion Oh I thought there was one more
thing I guess it's just those two
there you go see it see the
potion making app I saw a lot of people
on Twitter saying they're getting Vibes
of Half Blood Prince that's the first
thing I thought of too
that looks very similar to the Half
Blood Prince potion making obviously
updated and refined hopefully then we
had this one for accio what will you
summon
which hold on I think I think these have
sound let me turn off our other music
I think they have sound anyway let's see
yeah I know they do because I remember
him Akio
well I'll just do a couple times how
will you cast
hoacher stalker
which to start off here
how about the Gryffindor represent
represent uh collect Field Guide pages
in Hogwarts so this is the shot of the
library right here I love this love this
so they're in the library we have this
ancient I mean that looks like the the
statue that we've seen of the witch in
several different areas or maybe that's
the founders I don't know maybe that's
the founders
but I think finding all these Field
Guide pages is going to be so fun here's
one thing I thought was so weird in this
shot right here
oh by the way Megan hold on I missed
Megan's uh Megan with a super chat Mega
thank you so much
apologies apologies that I missed that
two minutes ago Megan said game comes
out 8 P.M here in AK oh nice
that's Alaska right not Arkansas yeah
Alaska
wow so you get it super early that's
awesome
but um yeah these Field Guide pages I
think they're gonna be so fun but what's
what I'm confused by is this right here
exit the mine
like clearly we're not in a mine
I don't know if it's just referring to
this point here
that you need to
foreign
why wouldn't it say go to the mine
I mean no way this is inside a mine
right this is definitely in Hogwarts
oh yeah collect fuel cap ages in
Hogwarts but then exit the mine it's got
to be something to do with the mission
whatever that mission right there is
and then uh
couple that we already know about so
incendio here
this one's accio so Akio is the purple
and then arresto momentum
and I'm thinking
a lot most people are thinking this is
Expelliarmus because the wand
which I think Alan called these damage
spells it's kind of interesting if he
would say
if Expelliarmus is in damage but I mean
it makes the most sense too
UK is five hours ahead of Eastern Time
have to wait even longer oh oh man
so wait a second you have to wait until
welcome by the way Shadow guide It's a
hold on
so you guys don't get to play it before
us you don't get to play it at midnight
your time
what time do you all get to play it
I figured it would still be it do they
go based on like eastern time is that
like when it all starts
uh yes Steph and there is gonna be a day
one patch that's in the uh the FAQ
maybe the 72-hour Early Access but no no
the 72 hour early access that's for uh
that is for PC Xbox series SX and PS5
yeah
yep not for any of the versions that got
delayed though unfortunately inner fire
gaming what is up I can pre-download it
on the fifth
nice I don't know why it's saying
different things for some people maybe
it's a territory thing I'm not sure
pre-order the steam version will take no
time to install nice
yeah that's what I was wondering Pete so
it's like eastern time is that what they
go by for release
Roger welcome Roger
Wi-Fi is bad by the time it's downloaded
The Early Access
no Lydia if you get the I think that's
why they open it up usually I guess some
people were saying 24 hours or 48 hours
before on Playstation so you can set the
download before you can actually play it
so it can go ahead and fully download
and I'm sure I know PC has that I'm sure
Xbox does too where you could have it
any Xbox users confirm the 72 hour I
mean that I'm pretty sure that's
official on the Early Access
laughs
can play four days early I do not know
anything about that Sam
I do not know anything about that Micah
a glad you made it as well Micah
all right let's let's watch the rest of
this here so you get plus 80 XP for that
and we see another accio here which we
still have the little marker here I
wonder if that exit the mine is actually
supposed to go with this one
it is I'm an idiot I'm an idiot welcome
to Gryffindor oh my gosh you guys okay
now it makes much more sense I just
remember freezing it right here and
being like what exit the mind I know
how are you goodness guys welcome to
Gryffindor yeah so the eggs at the mine
goes with this scene right here which
obviously wait makes a lot more sense
how are you oh my goodness nearly
headless Nick what has happened my
friend did we get another uh we did
Roger Roger with five more gifted tier
one memberships
we got five more members of house rack
and tour welcome my friends
welcome we're now officially how are you
welcome to Gryffindor officially members
of house rack Contour let's see who got
those Christian gamer got one that's two
months uh Debbie Logan Harry AAA EO and
then uh Logan Paul getgowan as well nice
guys welcome and thank you so much Roger
thank you very much and then did I miss
fetch Quest gaming fetch Quest gaming
oh wait fetch Quest gaming came in right
before
right before Roger fetch Quest gaming uh
renewed there or became a member thank
you so much fetch Quest thank you guys
thank you for all the support enjoy your
emotes have fun in the chat I think we
said it so you can spam them
all right let's see are they shortening
the recipes for potions yeah I'm like
two two does seem a little small some of
you guys are saying that feels like uh
say Hogwarts likes it would be 85
gigabytes
almost the same as Ragnarok
they're probably accio wands I wonder if
we could be uh so Ryan that's how that's
Expelliarmus
Expelliarmus will disarm and then pretty
sure it always uh
I said pop the wand back
oh my gosh hold on
oh my goodness
I know chat's already answered me you
guys have already answered me
it's the disarming spell drive out a
weapon forces the subject to drop
whatever they're holding usually that's
a wand which is why it's often seen in
duels
yeah so it just makes him drop it and
then I guess you could try to accio the
one
try to accio the one maybe
but I feel like something happened I'm a
little fuzzy on Deathly Hallows right
now
and that one's always different because
Harry was the true Master of the Elder
Wand but I remember obviously the front
cover of the book he ends with like the
wand in his hand so I think the wand
like flies back to him in that one
all right hold on
I'm gonna finish watching this clip
finally
oh did she go eat
my wife's like terrified of her voice
being on stream
she like barely opens the door
I asked the question she's just nodding
it's like it's okay honey they can hear
your voice it's it's fine
it's fine
yeah I know I know there's got to be
some some lore thing with that
but like I guess Expelliarmus
you're right they do show in the movie
we'll look at we'll look into it later
so then we get we get the scene right
here with the uh exit the mine
we see the little marker right there
clearly there in some sort of I mean
this could potentially be
Gringotts Maybe
I love the the attire right here by the
way the hat right there is awesome
and it is interesting with them being so
attentive to lore I'm honestly like I'm
surprised like I it personally doesn't
bother me some people says said it
bothers them but it honestly surprised
me that they did not make this Carpe
retract them
because technically
I think Carpe retract them is the one
that's that's like rope-like the
extension to pull you know
um I mean I guess it still technically
works because you're you're basically
pulling the lever
that then activates that so
and then I also wanted to comment on
these little uh these final
these little dueling Feats here slice a
poacher duelist while they're casting
reducto
so reducto confirmed spell dude maybe
that's oh I wonder if that's reducto
right there
because hold on what is
what are the exact effects of reducto
um reduce obstacles to pieces
that
a curse that blasted objects to pieces
it was rather easy to Target a fine mist
or a pile of Ashes Harry Potter taught
this curse to Dumbledore's army during
the 1995-96 school year it's blue
destroys solid objects
so I mean I guess that could actually be
reducto right there
by the way thanks to the uh new
subscribers guys welcome welcome
your PS5 comes Thursday
let's go dude
let's go
yeah they're they're pretty uh
consistently available now which is nice
to see
all right so that was the one that they
posted on the ninth and then today they
posted this one pretty straightforward
on this one Remember The Witcher wizard
always has the final say as to which
house they belong to
and it's just like the Sorting here hat
here where will you be sorted
feels super interesting to me they never
made one of these for fig
never made one for fig also never made
one for Weasley
maybe they're wanting to keep Weasley
somewhat of a secret to the the
mainstream audience who hasn't
dissected excuse me every single thing
like we have maybe
um so yeah that was today's
and yeah that's it
oh man we need a good you know what we
need a good poll question for tonight
we need a good poll question
all right let me see here what would be
a good one
now that we're much closer to Launch
no wait I don't want to go to that page
I want to go to this page oh my goodness
then I hear my voice my voice double
right there all right let's see
let's do start a poll
and I'm gonna say have you
pre-ordered
Hogwarts Legacy
yes no
I'm gonna add two no options no
I'm gonna say no waiting for Impressions
I'm gonna say Hands-On impressions
I'm not even gonna say reviews
I can't fit all that I'm just gonna say
waiting for Impressions no
don't plan to
if anybody in this chat right now votes
no don't plan to I'm gonna be very
curious the wire hanging out here
it'd be so funny if somebody's like
actually retro I just love your streams
I have no interest in this game
what what
all right there we go
there we go
all right so the other big thing I want
to do tonight is we are going to break
down
we've been trying to do this for what
chat the regulars who are here we've
been trying to do this for like three
weeks now
this this most recent gameplay showcase
we have broken down piece by piece
piece by piece
all right I'm gonna put it I'm gonna put
it right here at the combat section
I'm gonna get caught up with chat and
then we will uh we'll see where it's at
we'll Dive In
Dustin you were tempted but no don't
plan to now
foreign
wait till day before since you get
digital yeah
I mean the only reason I did is because
of the collectors which
even now I've had second thoughts about
if I want to keep it or not
it's not sad man isn't that sad
but I mean I don't want to insult people
who are excited for it
what's the accio clip Jax uh it was a a
new post they shared on their social
media accounts on
yesterday
yesterday yeah so you can find it on
Instagram
and or
uh Twitter as well
oh dude I freaked out for a second my uh
we have like this motion camera out
front and it just went off
like who in the world but it's uh it's
my mom my mom's coming tonight to uh
watch watch the kids the next couple
days
all right
Christian gamer yes last month Professor
Baxter said no but partly waiting for
Impressions partly because I'm too broke
now oh Professor Baxter
all right Luna now that somebody's here
she's gotta go out and yeah
she's got to go out and say hi
she goes crazy when my mom gets here
partly waiting for Impressions partly
because you're too broke oh yeah I mean
well Professor Baxter honestly like you
know take care of yourself first right
you got to take care of you and your
needs for sure
save up maybe you got some games you
could trade in
and wait for that first discount right
wait for that first discount because I
mean these days man it doesn't take long
for games to start getting discounted
I've also wondered like I wonder if this
game will ever appear on
like PlayStation Plus or Game Pass if
it's on Game Pass I feel like it would
it's definitely not going to be the
first year
definitely not the first year with the
uh Sony exclusives
and I feel like Sony would want to wait
oh that'd be crazy though if like after
that first year if it goes free to play
well not free to play but if it goes
free for um PlayStation Plus and then
Game Pass
Prater for PS5 digital Deluxe physical
PS5 get PC later on Yo Roger
nice Roger
yeah I'm probably not gonna keep
I'm gonna have to decide which uh
because I when I first pre-ordered the
the uh Deluxe physical it was really as
a backup
in case the collectors fell through
but um
or in case I decided I didn't want the
collectors which by the way I do want to
I want to check something real quick
because I can't remember
what box does the okay so I was like
yeah the collector's box
it includes both the
no wait when Chandler unboxed his
that's right it did not include
okay It's All Coming Back to Me Now it
only included the steel book it did not
include
the standard one even though it's
pictured here
I'm still I'm still confused about that
still a little confused about that
wait what did Mary say somebody said
they agreed
Draco here in the house as well can't
wait to hear you voice some of the
Hogwarts Legacy characters oh
dude that's gonna be fun
yo house in the house Welcome House good
to see you here
thankful pindo is the one that looks
like a slash I think the explosion is
Billy armis so the slash one is
definitely defendo
you can hear that in the IGN footage
with no commentary
your computer had updates and took
forever
it's all good he didn't miss too much
procrastination has you waiting till
pre-install yeah I mean like
I get it dude I get it if you're not
totally sold on the game why pre-order
even if you are sold on the game
it's like what's the point in
pre-ordering
unless you want some kind of extra that
is one thing that has surprised me man
is that we haven't seen more retailers
like in some countries they're getting
like all these fun little uh
fun little Trinkets and items
for pre-ordering
but yeah we haven't really uh gotten
anything in the US
Museum pre-ordered when it was launched
two Deluxe editions Draco one for PS5
one for PC
work trip oh my gosh
no no just just regular work regular
work
yeah my mom comes and watches so my wife
works in the medical field so she
doesn't work like a traditional schedule
so she's off sometimes during the week
yeah my wife we're uh we're taking off
to Utah for a couple days no I'm kidding
I'm kidding
no Dustin I yeah no showcase for me
oh my gosh literally everybody typing
work trip work trip work trip
yeah explosion spell right the explosion
one is confringo yeah
uh laser Rio it's because there's
digital only and disk Edition consoles
can't make a collector edition for
digital consoles only with a game disc
so it'll come with a code
no no it comes with a hard copy of the
game
unless you're talking about something
else for for the consoles it comes with
a hard copy
the collectors
and I think it even might say on here
somewhere
okay let's just say we're gonna go PS5
we're gonna say GameStop
I don't think it does say here but it
does uh
Chandler did confirm it when he unboxed
it
that it comes with a hard copy
but yeah then to your point uh God of
War did it the opposite
they did it the opposite the collectors
was a digital copy
Rachel really wished PC had a physical
copy want the case for the artwork of
this PC I feel like I've asked this on
stream before
are there any physical PC games anymore
any at all
I'm not a big PC Gamer like I have no
idea
I feel like somebody told me that they
do still do
some some physical games for PC
welcome to the new Subs by the way thank
you guys thank you for being here
uh yes Ryan that's correct you can get
the dark arts packs separate
isn't the last purple icon spell reducto
gosh maybe it's not fresh in my memory I
just did a video on that though so
I don't think I talked about
I don't know they're all running
together in my head
uh exactly Professor Baxter I hope so
too that's what I said on Chandler's
tweet like I just
excuse me man drinking this uh just a
regular Coke Zero tonight but keeps
giving me the
I don't know it's like a cross between a
it's not like a full-on hiccup
but um
yeah I can't wait for that moment I'm
hoping that this game
you guys I hope that it just has so much
to explore and do
after he beat the main game to where
we're just like exploring the cat like I
would love to be doing streams where
we're like working together you guys
viewing the stream we've already beat
all the story stuff now we're just
exploring and we're like working
together to like figure something out I
don't know if if any of you out there
play Destiny Destiny has been like
phenomenal for having these giant
puzzles that like take they design them
in such a way and of course this is not
a multiplayer game so they probably
wouldn't do this but
I know Chandler who obviously Chandler's
Community manager he didn't like
actually develop part of the game but I
know he's a big fan of Destiny
so if they had anything like that I know
he would just be all over that I would
just love if we had something that we
could like even if we can't jump in and
play the game together something that we
have to work on collaboratively to
figure out oh that'd be so awesome
but even if it's not stuff like that
stuff that we just like can explore and
and find all these little hidden Easter
eggs and secrets because you know
there's got to be so many there's got to
be so many
uh TJ I think I'll just do retro first
name last name raconteur
because you're trash what Lauren no
I never said that
one PS5 for you and then one for your
daughter
pre-order just for the three day early
access sex says
all right
and then we also had a
let's see
by the order of noob stay hydrated yo
you got it Noob you got it my friend
oh Christian gamer that's yeah I feel
like we're living in the world of Wally
at this point
if you guys didn't see Christian Gamers
comment they said I just like not having
to get up it's switch out the discs
what's funny is it's so true it's so
true man
and plus when you have kids any of you
any of you parents out there you know
what I'm talking about man
you know what I'm talking about they're
grubby little hands and they're they
just they like eat their snacks and then
they're oh I'm gonna play this game and
they're and they're messing with the
disc and the disc is all their
fingerprints are just all over it
to be able to just be like nah it's all
digital
by the way Pro tip for all the parents
out there or any of you who are about to
become parents
when your kids get ready to start gaming
Pro tip
just go ahead and bite the bullet buy
them a controller or get better yet buy
yourself a new controller and then give
them your controller
trust me trust me just trust me on that
if you got two kids by get two
trust me
oh dude I learned the hard way I learned
the hard way
trauma not quite trauma but absolutely
yeah
come in one day and I'm like what what
is all over this controller why is it
why is this button not pressing when I
push it
oh man there are some cool YouTube
videos though of like
it's like oddly relaxing of people who
like they'll like fully disassemble the
controllers and you know clean it with a
little alcohol
or if or if you don't want to go to that
trouble you can take like an old
toothbrush put it in some alcohol and
then kind of brush around in the buttons
obviously while it's powered off of
course but
but yeah don't forget to do that don't
forget
Pika pie can we talk can we just talk
about how in Hogwarts Legacy we can
place items in diagonal rights yes which
be hey Pinkie Pie thank you for getting
me on on subject here that's the title
or that was in our thumbnail
we want to make that a focus of the
stream tonight let's get this out of the
way first and then we'll do like uh
we'll do some q a at the end
when we wrap up the stream but um I
wanted to make sure we talked about this
so we completed this most recent
gameplay showcase so we've officially
talked about
broken down all the different sections
so if you're new here if this your first
time a couple weeks ago on stream we
said hey let's break down this hole
we'll do it all in one stream
we made it through this first section
this first exploration section then so
that was a big long multi-hour
discussion then I made a YouTube video
on it much more distilled down then we
did the same thing a couple weeks later
or at the very next week on the uh the
combat so the scenes that we just
watched here the combat video is up on
that on the channel as well and then
tonight we've finally reached the point
here we finally reached the point where
we're ready to talk about the room of
requirement and or the vivariums
also Pica pie I don't remember if you
were here last week if you're the same
Pinkie Pie that's on Twitter though we
we quoted we talked about one of your
tweets last time on stream I'm pretty
sure
what time your child niece was eating
crackers wanted to see my controller
sneeze
oh no
[Music]
spiritual phase uh that's I was asking
some of the UK folks earlier and didn't
he I I'm also very behind on I got very
behind on comments so the UK folks out
there may have answered this but I don't
know you guys how does it normally work
so just for any for games in general UK
folks who are watching win
when the game goes live digitally do you
guys is it like midnight your time
or is it like
does it go based on us eastern time I
honestly have no idea I can't believe
I've
I have no idea about this but I feel
like when you ever whenever you're like
on Twitch or something you know you got
streamers worldwide on there
I feel like it usually is based on
Eastern Time Zone
Batman says the time for Hogwarts Legacy
deluxe edition time to play is sometime
at 6 a.m in Canada time see that one
makes like anything past
however however you look at time
um
so we got 12 a.m midnight eastern time
Canada is going to be a little bit not
quite midnight yet
same thing for folks in West Coast
mountain time Central Time in the U.S so
you would just subtract you know
whatever it is that's when you would be
able to play
yeah I don't know how it works in the UK
if they go based on that or not
supernature oldest brother in your
family also flies to siblings as well
bought them all their all their own
controllers broke two of your ex oh man
they haven't broken actually I take that
back
my youngest son completely just
destroyed the like the grip on the
switch on the left joy-con just totally
gone like all that's left is the plastic
the plastic nub that's it
it just completely right and and yeah I
I don't I probably don't want to know
how exactly it happened to be honest
right that oh yeah pineapple Sam that
mysterious like why is this so sticky
what is going on
all right let's trying to catch up with
the okay let's see
but I think it was
it was stream I can't even remember what
it was about oh I think it was when we
were talking about um we were talking
about hype and expectations and I'm
pretty sure you had a
an interesting tweet on like how you
consider hype and expectations different
thing we talked about that a little bit
and then let's see we had Trent becoming
a member of House wreck and tour Trent
thank you so much
welcome you are officially a member of
House rack and tour thank you for being
here enjoy the emotes
you also get a special Discord role you
get discounted merch
man the the community the members here
guys continues to grow continues to grow
I was checking it the other day I
couldn't believe it couldn't believe it
man your old support is so so much
appreciated and then we also had a new
subscriber as well Christopher thank you
my friend
all right let's see what the UK folks
are saying here some games have local
unlock time others don't depends on the
publisher interesting spiritual fuse
says I guess so retro I believe it's
midnight for us so like your time
midnight
dude then that means all the UK guys are
gonna they're gonna be streaming it
I need to ask uh
some of the other the Hogwarts Legacy
YouTubers who are in uh in the UK
same thing since your time zone changed
when you moved oh so yeah Christy if
you're if you're central time now you
will be like you'll get to play it at 11
PM your time
instead of having to wait till midnight
it depends where the game is from Lydia
says
uh Roger says if something releases at
midnight it's usually right yeah exactly
games go live at midnight in the UK okay
Steven so then you guys are gonna get to
play it before us
no way
oh man
you guys are gonna be taunting me in the
chat then it's like we're counting down
like haha I'm already playing
foreign know if the PS5 controller
lights up for the PC version
good question Natasha good question
I do not know like if they have I think
your larger question is does it have the
like dual sense features and stuff that
they talked about as being
that's a good question because I know
Spider-Man it does
laughs
Valhalla was midnight in the UK and
pre-download 24 hours before on PS4
gotcha
uh Todd been told that here in New
Zealand it will come out New Zealand
time
does that mean New Zealand would get the
game first I'm assuming
maybe yeah I feel like they need
additionally confusing because there's
this whole Early Access period right
for pre-orders it depends on the game
some games have local time unlock others
have oh yeah that's what somebody else
was saying same time all over the world
I could see them doing that super Niche
I could see them being like we're having
a worldwide
unlock time
uh Bella waiting till April had PS4
gonna uh ghost on all Bella I'm so sorry
that's gonna be so rough having to like
avoid everything
oh nice rusty Titanic back in theaters
on February 10th
Sam it goes midnight Country Time
typically on Xbox you can set your time
zone Disney and play it at New Zealand
what does it work that easily
Chris basically we're living in the past
present in future future
we all experience time differently
Fallout 4 came out set your V oh yeah I
could see how it would work with a VPN
yeah yeah for sure
I could definitely see how it would work
with a VPN
yeah some of the others saying VPN stuff
too
all right we're gonna need yeah
I feel like we need some clarification
from the dev team
hey just like for the Early Access if
you've if you pre-ordered digital Deluxe
when does the game unlock for you
and I will I will hit up some of the UK
folks as well on on Twitter who I know
are
pre-ordering the game
see what if they can like check in their
PS5 if it says yeah like what time
oh oh hold up silverheart says PSN says
midnight on the 6th UK time can confirm
oh my goodness dude
you guys are gonna be playing before us
no way
no way yeah that sounds correct Adam
yeah
oh my goodness yeah so who like what
what time zone is the
furthest
like who would who will be the first
country to get to play Hogwarts Legacy
that's what JP's trying to figure out so
Melbourne Australia plays it first
we need to ask Jim
Noob finally home 2 22 A.M
oh my goodness wait Noob are you in the
UK Noob I don't think I knew you were UK
how did I not know that new one of the
regulars here on the stream Sinjin
almost always played MMOs so I'm used to
a worldwide start time
yeah this is like single player so I
don't know how they're gonna handle it
possible because the Wizarding World is
bored I I see I saw you as still a
member there if that is the same
knowledge Dylan what is up dude with the
five gifted memberships
welcome take it away nearly headless
Nick wait he's over there he's up there
go for it Nick appreciate it Dylan my
friend thank you so much for the five
gifteds right there Dylan a regular here
on the Stream
and we have five new members of house
record tour we got Northwest gaming
that's two months for Northwest gaming
sanguine
I think that's how you pronounce that
how are you Tales welcome to Gryffindor
Channel member as well Todd Channel
member it's philosophy three months
right there for its philosophy and then
icy got one of those gifted as well so
enjoy the emotes guys
enjoy the emotes and the special Discord
role if you're a Discord person and want
to join hop in over there
discounted merch
etc etc
and oh wait hold on I forgot the hammer
I forgot the hammer once you become
members
of house tracking tour my friends I
really I should probably just bring one
of my wands down here instead
so I've been able to lift this every day
I mean it's so heavy guys it's so heavy
you know
it's very it takes a very uh a lot of
strength to lift that weapon right there
a lot of strength
didn't have to use a VPN Turtle
literally just change the time zone
uh Holly Melancholy that sounds right
yeah for Central yep
Osiris what's up dude welcome if VPN
works that's just too easy we're all
gonna be like researching vpns tonight
how much does a VPN cost and how early
dude you guys
oh man you're seriously gonna be giving
me a hard time doing the live stream our
countdown stream I just know it
I just know it dude
oh there he goes okay I see your whole
comment now spiritual
um sure makes sense guys okay thoughts
on the Elder one storyline or DLC or
something that would be neat to somehow
link what we know to this original story
of the game
um
I think there's some opportunity yeah
opportunity for sure careful with any
spoilers guys
if you've read the trophy list we
consider that spoiler so don't
don't allude to anything that may or may
not be in there related to
the uh
the original series we'll just we'll
just put it like that way
some people are trying to go in
completely completely blind
completely blind
yeah so sounds like you all it sounds
like everybody's gonna get it you know
based on local time so UK folks maybe uh
Australian friends New Zealand friends
you guys might be playing it early
might be getting it early
cyber ghost or VPN
I think so Eagle Eye yeah we were
talking about this at the start of the
stream I'm gonna start off here
we're gonna do I don't know the exact
timing yet I'll announce all the details
but we'll like start here that Monday
and work our way up to
midnight and then I'm gonna switch over
to Twitch to do the actual gameplay so
that way for people who don't wanna
you know makes it easy to hop out
but then uh probably gonna be doing all
the pure gameplay on Twitch and then
I'll bring those over over later to
YouTube as their own kind of Let's Plays
hold on nearly headless Nick going crazy
again because Blue Moon just gifted five
tier one memberships all right hold on
I've gotta you guys are gonna give me a
workout tonight
oh goodness the hammer
welcome to the members of house
raconteur my friends thank you all for
being I should just keep it right here
on the desk but I like it as a prop in
the back I like having it back there
oh Blue Moon thank you so much Blue Moon
always showing love and support in the
Stream very much appreciated and it just
got uh the flash unsung hero Asher's Dad
what's up Asher's dad three Hillary
Brothers all just got a membership here
to the channel now you can have access
to all those emails there in the chat
and uh get discount on merch special
Discord roll so enjoy it guys thank you
all for being here
uh correct unsung hero yeah digital no
disc for that
but yeah I think so Eagle Eye I was
trying to decide like how late I'm gonna
go
might try to get a lot of rest that that
Monday
that's that's how we got that's actually
how we got to this conversation you guys
it's because I was trying to figure out
exactly um
figure out exactly how much time when
it's gonna be hitting all that stuff
yeah Professor Baxter yeah yeah so we're
playing through Goblet of Fire right now
I'm wanting to stream later this week
it'll be evening streams because uh but
Monday so next Monday we're we're closed
for Martin Luther King Jr day my wife
also happens to be off work so I think
that's almost definitely going to be a
twitch stream day
so um yeah if you guys are in the
Discord you'll you'll see I'll make sure
I make it make the announcement there
but yeah I want to do a lot more streams
man I had so much fun streaming the
Goblet of Fire game even though the game
is like bad it's not good but just
hanging out with you guys as we as we
play is fun
ah
Christy staying up coffee and all Dylan
Sonic fan the Hedgehog Dylan what is up
dude man Dylan
Dylan the Sonic fan Dylan not our other
Dylan
one of the mo like every tweet I post
Dylan you're always there showing love
dude thank you so much man I see you and
all and on the YouTube videos too
and on the YouTube videos I was trying
to scroll back up and see if uh
if narlet responded but I think I'm
already so far behind I've missed the
comments now to see if that was the same
gnarlet I used to play Destiny with
I think there's gonna be some sort of
one customization laughing stock yeah I
do I don't know what though
because obviously they have to be
careful with um
with lore right they don't want it to go
too far
I love that niffler emote dude I love
that niffler emote so much yeah congrats
on all the gifteds you guys
uh I think I missed it TJ changing
location
hold on somebody said yo retro
somebody said yo retro I was just like
okay this person seemed really excited
to be here so I gotta scroll back up and
say hi to them
who was it
who was it
saw somebody join the Discord fellow
Hufflepuff
where's all the hufflepuffs at in the
chat
if you just unlocked if you're a channel
member you got access to the Emojis
to show your house colors
Sharon that's who it was missed anything
nope sure we're just getting started
we are an hour and 35 minutes into the
stream now
and the topic for tonight's discussion
ladies and gentlemen the room of
requirement
the room of requirement
all right here we go so this is the part
guys this honestly like still
has blown me away something that Ben
even makes the comment in the Showcase
of like we never expected this level of
customization some utility as well which
we didn't I mean everybody knew room
requirement 100 it's going to be in the
game
but what the heck are you gonna be doing
in there you know it's a room that can
morph to so many different things what
are we going to be doing in there
well here we go let me turn this up for
a bit potions we are going to be putting
the dark arts away put those
unforgivable curses away Chandler you're
like you're loud too you're loud there
we go your home within Hogwarts a
personalizable space uh that actually
has some utility as well where you get
to that is not 4K I don't know what's
going on with it right now uh also care
for some beasts
all right Andrew's got us in the room of
requirement I mean just this first room
we kind of went casual mode on the
outfit here wearing a nice jump which by
the way
a little niffler right here
not really sure what's this one over
here
jumper
um and and I just love how alive this
room feels like you walk in there's
there's so much happening I mean your
eyes obviously they focus kind of there
in the middle but there's so many other
little interesting like you've got the
different vivariums here
which is a word I've heard pronounced so
many different ways
I'm pretty sure I heard it vivarium if
you look it up on Webster's it's
vivarium but then in the first trailer
they they said vivariums I don't know
we're just gonna go we're just gonna
roll the variums that makes that sounds
the best to me
but yeah you got the two other ones up
here a lot of people are thinking maybe
this one's water aquatic based I think
it looks more like Arctic or cold
but maybe I mean it could be rain forest
could be water themed as well
and this one over here I don't even know
I think that's a good jumping off point
jumping yeah kind of like this glowing
green here but then all like you got the
owl over here you've got the the hopping
pot you can't see the hopping pot right
now
there you go there's the hopping point
for uh the personalization of the space
the loom which they talk a lot more
about here in a bit as well not just
your character and I mean so the fact
that we can
here in a second they literally show you
customizing this right here
they show you customizing this right
here so can you
like what all like if you walk along
this
like like this right here this little
horn
can you choose to take that down and put
something else there and the visuals of
your character but actually this space
is a place that you can make your own
um yeah it was super important to us
that this space really did feel like
um your reflection uh as a wizard so you
can change the architecture which by the
way I hear that like the flapping of
wings and
um your reflection
um trying to figure out if this is one
of the The Little Pages up here if you
guys look right up here
left one is swamp right when it's water
I do feel like swamp yeah I'm still not
sold on a bee in water
I think you all are probably right but
I'm still not 100 sold
but the space really did feel like
um you're yeah JP it could be more it
could be more change the architecture in
here
uh yeah Ben you could tell he's just
totally
you can change the architecture in here
because when they first said
customization I'm thinking oh okay like
you can rearrange these big like these
tables right here your little potion
area and all that no as a wizard so you
can change the architecture in here
different she just stops she just stops
to to smile his reaction I love it
did they confirm the left one was swap
nice
Coastline icy says yeah see that's why
I'm like
I want it to be I I see why people say
water I do but I'm not I'm not like a
hundred percent sold that it's water
themes throughout uh starkly different
themes my jaw dropped at this right here
yeah so I guess those aren't missing
pages maybe they're just books flying
around up there
because there's multiple ones I I don't
think they put that many in one area
here's my question how many more of
these are there
how many more of these because you see
the little uh the right on the d-pad
here you've got one two three four
options right here so Botanical main
ceiling is the one they just switched to
what
Alan he loves it dude scientific main
ceiling also you could change the color
which I don't I don't remember if they
get into that right here
I don't think they do yeah they don't so
change color you have the option to
change color which I'm like
I wonder if it means like the little
Outer Rim area just Hammer home though
this is this is yours
because I don't think you're going to be
changing the color of the obviously the
greenery is going to stay and maybe it's
like the beams here
Reddit post confirmed water Reddit wait
Reddit post
official Reddit like like Chandler's
read it
silver heart
running theories that there will be five
in total
four to specific biomes and the main
Beast room being a more multi-biome yeah
because that for the one that we've seen
and we go into a lot yeah it is kind of
a multiple
there is a little Coastline there for
that one beautiful we never expected
that to be
architecture here but you can actually
now McKenzie's like oh oh I got him he's
he's so excited let me show you what
else we can do
it's like those old infomercials but
wait there's more objects here it is
into this space as you can see so
dude I I don't think I've actually ever
looked at each of these individual icons
as you can see so
yo have a good night Dylan Dylan always
catching up on the replay Squad thank
you for being here Dylan so look this
one right here obviously confirming
seasonal
uh then we have potions so this one we
see is potions right here we got a
little leaf right here so
I mean is that trees and Greenery
flowers
this one's probably like animals on the
oh what's it called Taxidermy you know
where they're on the wall
then you've got the wrench here so
you've got the rugs and you've got the
furniture
artwork that one's got to be artwork
right there but then wait why do they
have separate
so this one's table then like statues
little stands
three more Tuesdays I know I know it's
crazy I'm Billy May's here oh my gosh
eat their blast from the past
R.I.P didn't Billy Mays pass away I
think Billy Mays passed away several
years ago
I think he passed away
I know the holiday items of cell poem
for that
oh
okay that one that one uh they hovered
on is rugs right there into this space
as you can see so
there's like yeah Dustin I think it was
something like that unfortunately
I think it was let's see the lab
athletic yo thank you for becoming a
member here welcome to house wreck and
tour my friend enjoy your emotes which
you can now spam at your
at your whim as much as you want there
in the chat
welcome welcome thank you
uh 2009's when he passed away
statues so that one said okay wait in
position I got sidetracked I got
sidetracked by the member an assortment
of embellished rugs is what you see for
that one
and then the next one here we go then
they go into the rug so this one medium
scientific rug medium rug that would
feel right at home in a library
so I guess it cost the Moonstone to
conjure them statues that you can do and
ornaments and tables and rugs and just
and then I wonder if that's like a
one-time cost so you have your
conjuration budget
conjuration budget indicates the total
number of items that can be conjured so
that's probably like just a
to keep people from I mean obviously
there's physical limitations in terms of
the data that can be stored in this area
right so it'll be interesting to see how
quickly that fills up like how densely
packed can we make this
um and then the resources required I
wonder if that's a one-time thing or
like every time like if I decide I want
to change the rug
or maybe it's like once you buy it you
like you own it you have it in your
inventory a bunch of little things that
really flesh out the space and bring it
to life oh my goodness because like we
we had an idea that those places okay so
that one said a variety of chairs and
sofas oh my goodness because like we
which I believe is the bottom left one
idea right there yeah so that one they
call seating oh
dude
seating has to be confirmed right
seating has to be confirmed right
right so would you put seating in the
game
that those places where you brew stuff
that's where you can change but you can
do oh Jenny nice you get it back when
you remove the items all of this where
do you even get this stuff like there's
a right there they got 20 for that one
through stuff that's what you can change
but you can do a whole of this and maybe
maybe it costs 20 to conjure that one
too that's it that's an interesting
system though so it's like okay
so you have to have enough if you want
to do a lot you get this stuff like
there's a Furniture 20 moonstones right
there yeah so we go and then I just love
how everything feels so alive like you
just have kind of the little objects
here the little
tea tea kettle there sort of floating
all them conjurations uh and the
conjuration magnifying glass purchased
at tomes and Scrolls and hogsmeade
um but also as you engage in a
botanically inspired chair with a floral
flare
different types of gameplay throughout
the world you'll be and then everyone of
course appreciates the diagonal
positioning possibilities right
step up it's going to be so different
from animal if you played a lot of
Animal Crossing like I have quite a step
up from that
uh let's see welcome to the new
subscribers there welcome and then we
also had D Jane Channel member for four
months thank you for the four months DJ
and for being a member of House rack and
tour for all four of these wonderful
months thank you retro for keeping us
hyped during this wait period have you
decided how you're going to stream the
Tuesday of release that's right DJ we
were just talking about that yeah so
we're gonna have a big countdown
it'll have to be the Monday though
actually we'll do like a big count down
here probably all sorts of fun and games
I don't have the firm plans yet but we
would definitely be going live that
evening and then at midnight we're going
to be trans we're going to hop over to
Twitch So for anybody who wants to watch
gameplay and you can hop over there but
that'll be like a nice like clear
breaking point for people who are like I
don't want to see anything
um and then all those videos will be
brought to Twitch eventually but yeah
can't wait can't wait it's gonna be fun
so then here you've got the color
options as well different objects so
cool you change the color you can change
the color
that one's really interesting to me the
fact that you can change size so are we
going to be able to invite like house
elves and then okay it goes bigger too
like giants half Giants can they can
they come hang out with us oh my God
you're so tiny
it's like her baby dude I didn't catch
that the first time I think we must be
able to customize this too watch right I
gotta do something
there
it actually sort of lights up right
there
so I wonder if we I I think that means
we can customize this whole little
entryway here too
that's how it looks to me
PC players making an arachnid Mount oh
you know it dude
uh let's see what is that Ali
Alit Ali Tama Ali Tama I think
agree with you but don't tell a lot of
the chat here don't tell them
please just do not tell them we did a
poll here before you see and asked how
many care about sitting
and the yes votes they won they actually
won
I know I don't get it either I'm not
going to be sitting down in this game
I'm not going to be sitting at all but
don't like
I think it was like 57 or so
we can't let them know about oh wait
what what did you guys hear something
but did you guys see I didn't hear
anything something about sitting yeah I
think sitting's probably in the game
right right I think
and I love how the the system oh I
didn't think about that laughing stock
what if you could completely re
completely move
completely change the entryway
yeah
two is designed it's not mechanical it's
immersive and so you might check I mean
in my mic cut out I don't know what
happened guys you're actually doing this
in the world as your magical effect of
conjuring it in and you're you're you're
actually doing this in the world as
you're yeah I love the little effect too
dude like look at that you can see
you're actually doing this in the world
as he's sort of jogging down the hall
you see a couple of those light up so
that means we can customize all those
that right there
probably customizable as well
but where is d dude I feel like Deke
should just be always hanging out in
here like that gameplay he's the one who
introduces us to this sign of
personalized all right so that was four
moonstones right there oh my God like
and I love the animation how it like
appears you know like it's not just like
there the animation is great it is
really really frilly cat plates a
collection of fussy frilly plates
displaying curious kittens
quite beautiful and that was the thing
is we wanted that to look really nice
because the Magic in The Wizarding World
is everywhere it's it's physical it's
kinetic and it's whimsical we really
wanted to nail that Whimsy in this space
another thing that I wanted to important
is that not only can you like and you
can change their their look but you can
do that with the utility objects as well
so you can see that we have planting
pots and Potions a Botanical potting
table perfect for growing three plants
requiring a small pot and you can also
change the color on these and it appears
that you can change like the positioning
as well like stations and you could
change the look of those as well and
these are the areas where as we had
mentioned previously you'll be growing
your plants you'll be brewing your
potions right right right right right
so while you're also doing these like
kind of nurturing straight to the trash
where you would bring your gear here to
be identified you make it your own
like
which I believe Alan can talk to oh yeah
um I we keep bringing up with parents
and and how I'm just noting all the
times that you see that little highlight
popping up that little white highlight I
mean it really does feel like it's
everything it works and and on the the
lamps right here I guess it's a lamp
like uh in the game you can look like
anything you want to whenever you want
to
um but the player will be finding
different types of I didn't even see
that the first time what game is this
chat here
um what game is that
is that a Wizarding World thing or is
that a real world game
that I don't know what the actual name
of it is
cat plates are oh dude you're right they
are very umbrage vibes
they are very Umbridge vibes
that's right Sinjin they did
they did
I still can't get over this room guys I
cannot
and then like you have this and then you
go into the whole other section
the vivariums backgammon okay
I was like this looks like a game I
should probably be
the only person okay what
Zeke will be my best friend no questions
asked
yeah hopefully Duke will be able to like
come in here and hang out with us
it's like incorrect back again I was I
was about to say backgammon but it I
yeah I think it's maybe something uh
unique to The Wizarding World I don't
know though
um I don't know but the player will be
finding different types of gear that we
call and this back here I didn't notice
this before either but that looks like
it almost looks like wand boxes but no
others
and types of
gear that we call it I was about to say
one customization over there no but that
that would be really lore breaking if
you can just like go pick
a completely random wand uh as you
progress to the game and essentially we
just know that that I know no uh no
chess or gobstones yeah and as you uh
but see like on that note I think if
they've replaced it with stuff like this
I'm not saying it's you know I know a
lot of people wanted it
but if they if they chose like you know
what if we don't do quidditch we can
instead make this whole
this whole area with all this
customization with all of this uh that
actually might be an interesting poll
question at some point like would you
have would you have traded all this all
this room of requirement stuff
all this customization all the bavarium
stuff would you've traded that for
quidditch I bet that'd be like a 50 50.
I bet because there's a lot of people
who want to Quidditch
as you explore and as You Adventure so
then we get to the loom over here the
enchanted Loom where you're going to
upgrade gear uh which we see the three
the um superb so superb is the blue one
and then legendary is what they're
calling the goldish orange ones and then
purple is your epic extraordinary and
then they have a green and probably
I don't know I wonder if they have one
usually some games have like one below a
green that's like a gray or something
different he says over here welcome to
Gryffindor Hannah Hannah thank you so
much for becoming a member of House
racket tour here you're now officially a
member enjoy the emotes and a special
Discord role as well uh for any of you
here hanging out if you're not part of
the Discord exclamation point rack into
her whoops didn't mean to do that we'll
get you
I was actually going to open up another
window here
because I wanted to see how many
how many likes are we at
oh my gosh we're already over 200. I
don't think anyone I can't believe the
mods haven't told me
I can't believe the mod probably because
they were trying not to derail me but
whenever we hit 100 likes we do a random
bit of Harry Potter quote trivia and
when we get 200 we have to do an
impression
from the Harry Potter series so stick
around for that stick around for that
after we get done with this here
but yeah thank you guys for all the
likes very much appreciate it helps more
people find the video find the Stream
this might be my whole my favorite
like looking through all of this
so we have protego shielding decreased
damage taken from dark Wizards
so I guess this applies to yeah this is
to the robes traits traits you have
collected so right here we have the
Cerulean rivet gloves
and they will have an offense and a
defense category here and then looks
like three levels of upgrade
and then you have trait requirements
here which require resources to do that
and so then we have we've discovered 25
total traits over here which they don't
scroll through all of them but
um you have decree decreased damage
taken from Doug bogs decreased damage
taken from goblins increased damage
taken from inferior spiders trolls and
then we have the lupus protection here
which some people are like which are
part of you kind of growing as a wizard
I wouldn't immediately assume werewolves
it could just be the wolves that we've
already seen could just be
yeah yeah exactly they're all level one
traits too all level one traits all the
time uh
we never whenever so hopefully there's
like more insane stuff and not just take
even more take even less damage from the
inferior you get a new piece of gear you
don't necessarily know exactly what it
does and so there's a station inside of
the room of requirement that you can
conjure it's one of the first things you
conjure uh called an identification
station where you can actually see
that's where they've made their way over
to you now you're uncertain about and
learn what its abilities are which noted
there are Gryffindor banners here on the
other side I believe they had Ravenclaw
so it seems that you'll be able to have
multiple
house options represented in here which
is kind of cool I think that's so cool
there's also people in the chat saying
that they uh you're kind of like a cross
between
multiple houses so you'll have to choose
one to play as but that'd be fun if you
can kind of have several in here
advances even further and the space will
eventually grow its own rooms and you're
going to get new recipes you know like
like McKenzie's talking about all these
different things keep expanding and as
it take too much damage and you become a
Hogwarts again
oh my goodness our character actually
dies and the end game you just explore
you can go and find all the Collectibles
but you play as a ghost from that point
on
could you imagine dude hey Sharon have a
good night thank you for being here
it's crazy Sharon we've only got a
handful of these left hopefully we'll
see you next week we got well I think we
said what three left chat before before
the launch week
to earn what we see here which is called
the loom and when you set up a loom it's
another back over at the loom yeah so
look there's a there's a Ravenclaw one
in the background right there
now so this one for the extraordinary it
requires trait level wait trait slot
level two
and then it has the Roman numerals here
for number two no trade applied
essentially customize exactly which
magical properties are on
so then you go over here to this one so
this one already if you do I guess if
you do this
you'll go from zero to four on the
defense on your gear and take any piece
of gear and adjust its properties and
tweak what it does and I mentioned
earlier that that you can make it which
by the way transmog the place with
confirmed
basically confirmed
you guys don't play a lot of games like
this transmog just means that you can
look like whatever you want but have
your the same upgrade so like if you
want to play with you know decreased
damage taken from goblins and you know
whatever other trait okay wait so these
are all okay so even though these are
level one you can still apply it
trait slot level two
of
um appearances we call it or Cosmetics
we've been referring to so he's talking
about the stream these types of things
you can use and you can apply a look to
any other other look so if you get a
piece of gear you put it on you look
like that but you can change it to look
like whatever you want
so cool and like you just you can just
put some ability to the sweater but then
you can just swap yeah that ability yep
and the appearances you can edit
whenever you want in the gear screen the
loom is specifically about applying uh
for the question earlier about what the
question on wands
that's why I think I don't think it will
be anything affecting the actual wand
I think it would be purely something
Visual and I don't think it I don't see
how they could do like one customization
in terms of
you know I don't think they're gonna let
you change your wood type and change
your core because that I mean that would
really kind of go against lore there but
the way they could do it is have
something like lucius's one where maybe
you customize it by your wants like in a
cane or something or you have a snake
head on on the end of it that you kind
of like work on and attach it there that
kind of stuff could be cool
could be cool
my newly headless Nick and not peeves
what even is like I've always wondered
like what exactly is a poltergeist like
how can you
how is that different from a a ghost
like did they St do poltergeists start
as a ghost but then they become these
malevolent
beings instead I I don't I don't know
how that works
oh wait hold on somebody was saying the
stats are tied to close but you can
change the looks of them right yeah you
could change it to any the looks of
anything you want yeah
that's kind of the idea of what they
call
transmogrification or something but most
people just call it transmog for short
crates and and applying uh larger so I
thought like maybe the legendaries would
have more
more slots but basically all it's saying
is that they can accept
trait slots that are tier three in their
quality or whatever you want to call it
is really what it's saying there
upgrades that just kind of grant you
manifestation of Mischief at Hogwarts
they say you like came with the building
Blended nicely with where you're trying
to go with your combat fantasy or
talents and things like that interesting
I'm just like I've just seen that
they're just like pumpkins
where does that come from yeah and so
you'll notice that the ingredients that
are used to add traits and to upgrade
your gear are based around beasts that's
how nasty and evil you were in life
section would you be interesting
Poltergeist is conjured of the students
bigger space on the inside
yeah and then this is like what then you
go in here I don't see how it would be
tied to the student Mischief because
they say he was there like before like
when they built
maybe that's just like one of those um
things that sort of changes over time
though
or maybe it was like kind of a joke like
he came with the building but really it
wasn't like from the moment they built
the building
which is inside this vivario
on a bigger space on the yeah see she
pronounced it vivarium then I've heard
vivarium and then vivarium inside so I
didn't catch this the first time
watching R1 here to manage beasts
and we still have our ancient magic
meter up in here that's interesting we
have a couple of beasts out we have a
crap horn and a moon calf and a niffler
and a nasal as well so I'll quite a
variety oh my God he's just like a big
puppy
and then what is this roaming over here
is that is that a niffler part of me I
got that together what is this right
here chat
look right right here it's gonna move
from right to left across your screen
here that's so cute they are adorable
and so part of Beast care uh is heading
them as well but feeding hold on one
more time
hey ilham welcome going back to sleep
just wanted to come by and say hi to
everyone wish you all a good night Day
morning hey thank you good to see you
very much
I was about to say platypus it's a
nipple they look at later okay
oh my God he does have that please care
that coloration
too and so once you do those things
that's when they feel safe enough to get
can they'll give you their magical
ingredients so mooncap for niffler fur
so you have to make them feel safe
enough before you can get their uh their
special ingredients oh yeah there he is
yeah yeah he walks right up to him yeah
it's the little niffler leftovers that's
so there's the little niffler there
making for them so in the Overland you
can find here's my question about all
this
how many times have I said that the
stream by the way I catch myself saying
that a lot like here's my question
here's my actually I have like you know
500 questions but for right now here's
my question they show
they show all of this like sweet caring
so cute and adorable immediately after
showing us the dark arts battle arena
so I'm like okay what if you're this
ridiculously Evil wizard
what can you do in here like do you have
to care for the creatures in here is
that the only thing or can you just
treat them terribly can you like work
with the poachers or something I don't
think so but that's gonna be such like a
weird transition to go from like
if you're playing Dark wizard path like
oh just aking everything oh now let's go
into the uh now to be fair for the uh
battle arena that one's a little bit
different right
but yeah I just thought that's it's like
such an interesting uh Dynamic there
back to back
here's my question the equivalent of
James is yo I actually I say yo a lot
too I've caught myself saying it I don't
know if it's James rubbing off on me or
if I just do it as well it's like it's
just such a good exclamation when like
oh there's a new uh a new member yo
thank you so much
you these beasts part of doing so is
brushing them oh she got cut off right
there listen rescue these beasts part of
doing so is rescue these beasts cut
uh part of doing so is maybe it's just a
mistake or maybe she was about to give
some super secret info feeding them
we'll never know
with your beef
they're for Beast you can actually uh
conjure things in this space as well uh
the house the cottage yeah yeah I wanna
I wish they had went in there I want to
see what is in there
and how customizable is that like then
can you customize Furniture in there
what
right and so we have like a lot of
little ornaments in this area and a lot
of them are purely cosmetic but they
look really cool again it's the
personalization so a lot of the stuff
here purely cosmetic as she mentioned
there's no this is like I'm gonna spend
eight hours just designing this whole
area to precise this is like cool it's
like you have this little I think people
will spend a lot more time than that bin
I think they will
you could always been yeah what exactly
did they say you I would guess they
filmed several different takes anyway
you would think you know so to say just
for the creatures I love it yeah no
totally and there's like a decoration a
solid Stone bench which is a natural
addition to any location respect leave
them to starve oh my goodness Dustin
utility aspect to it too so as you uh
progress in the game they take three
minutes to pop up Northwest no way
I'm on to the next thing
I don't know why that happens
all right let's let's test it everybody
type
yo in the chat right now one two three
four five six oh okay that's pretty
quick
six seconds
six seconds
all right so Northwest you exaggerated a
bit there clearly clearly with your
three I'm just kidding dude I'm just
kidding it's honestly it's probably me
it's probably because I I just I take a
little bit to scroll now there may be
there may be a delay on when it pops up
in the little uh visual right below my
screen I actually don't know how long it
takes to pop up there but
I actually do not know
can we sit on the stone bench I know I'm
so curious
I really wonder how customizable wands
be if we can carry over our
pm
p.m p.m P.M
I don't know what you mean by pm
carry over RPM
I wonder what happens if we don't take
yeah Tyler right like what if the people
are
why are we we were testing stream delay
Ray mcclaw Tyrell
we were testing out the stream delay
to see how long it took people from the
time I said
everybody type that in the chat it was
it was between five and six seconds oh
Pottermore Pottermore Pottermore okay
let me see what your comment was again
here
oh if we carry over a Pottermore I
wonder if we can edit the look at least
I mean they've they've already said that
you can basically chew even if you've
linked your account you can choose what
you like if you want to bring it over or
not
yeah if it's officially not Pottermore
anymore
not Pottermore anymore
I still have it as uh
Pottermore on my bookmark it still says
Pottermore all right so here they they
kind of skim over this pretty quickly
but most of us picked up on this
breeding pin the breeding pin can be
used to breed two beasts and produce
Offspring so you're just gonna be able
to set up like this little farming
Empire here to constantly generate all
these different resources that you need
Beast feeder right here so one of them
large Beast trough that keeps your bees
fed
Beast feeder budget one out of one so
I'm guessing you can only have one of
those like that's the max
I'll never not call it Pottermore I know
I know
that's funny Timothy no that's not what
I said yes sir which uh
for the beast in the space to
automatically and you get the little toy
box
oh wait hold on they skimmed over that
pretty quick
building the progression for yourself
here right there
okay so we got the brush here the one
they're hovering on now is called
building pieces a collection of old
buildings and structures that can be
assembled together
what do you think this one is just I
mean like different style brush I guess
Northwest I don't know why everyone else
can get theirs pop up so quickly sent my
yo right when he said it and you could
see how far down my message is hold on I
gotta find
I gotta find it now
Blue Moon noticed the flu flame at 26.51
oh okay yeah we'll go back and we'll go
back and check that
oh now I can't find I can't find when
you said it at all Northwest I can't
find it now
yeah I don't know why that is I don't
know if it's something to do with
internet connection or what sometimes
like a refresh of the stream now one
thing on YouTube is like you can like so
with YouTube live see how like I can
rewind this right here you can do the
exact same thing with lives so it's very
possible
make sure you're like fully all the way
over to the right I've done that before
by accident like accidentally clicked
and moved them back in the Stream yeah
all right let's see what um
what what was that timing again there
from Blue Moon 2651 sort of weird to
have it in there for Laura I think
I do remember that now that you uh
now that you mentioned that 26.51 oh
yeah right there here are based right
there yeah that is
yeah I I definitely think
and again I'm not fully up to my lore
on the travelings within Hogwarts
but I do think they they're definitely
taking some liberties with the flu
Flames just for a pure matter of
convenience like we know Hogwarts has
flu Flames like that that is you know
for sure it has flu flames
um
but
of course they're going to have stuff to
prevent people from the outside coming
in
and then this one like I guess the way
they're getting around it lore was like
you you had to Discover It originally
first for yourself and then once you
found it but you're right I mean like in
the books room of requirements like they
have to go back every time and find
where it is I think that's mostly a
gameplay thing yeah just to make it an
easier
yep function over form exactly I think
so
Jake what is up Jake welcome based
around beasts so this is where we get
into the Beast characters
got the little nasal there
cool again it's the person what do you
guys think uh about these little uh
I mean clearly that's it's still the
spell system here because we see the
little indicator over here
but I wonder if these are actual spells
a lot of people are saying that this is
like evanesco make it disappear or maybe
that maybe that's the one they're saying
is evanesco
hours just designed in this whole air
then they switch over to this one which
is like the brush and I guess feeding
here and then your bag it was like you
have this little oh dude so wait I
wonder if this is the same bag that we
that we use to rescue them when we're
out in the main in the in the main World
surrounding Hogwarts and then also the
same bag that we use to quickly summon
them from
because that'd be kind of cool if you
can like the creatures that you're
actually flying around on then you take
them back in your little bag and then
when you're here you can like let them
out here to play for a while
play area like a personalized fish tank
so to say that's true too Jenny yeah
I've thought about that a couple times
too like who knows what the rules were
in the 1890s with like
Hogwarts and blue flames but there's
also we were saying okay we already
watched this part
uh and there's also see here so easy so
you can um we already saw that part too
dangerous
for them you're really helping helping
them out there's poachers in the
Overland uh who want to who hunt these
Beasts for their material so instead
you're caring for them you're giving
them a home
so yeah that's where I'm anxious to know
if you're not a night soon if you're a
not so nice wizard though
but he looks like my dog
I forgot Ben said that oh
you could actually
actually rescuing your kidnapping dog oh
yeah this was so cool when they said you
can name it feed and brush this beast
and it will release magical materials
that can be woven into gear crap horns
are large mountain dwelling beasts that
have a tough hide and two sharp horns
the tentacle-like appendages on grab
horns faces are used for capturing food
and tending to their young grab horns
are known for their aggressive nature
however a witch or wizard has been known
to befriend one in rare circumstances
rare circumstances
look so getting back into that
personalization you know yeah we didn't
want you I love that they did this oh
here's a here's a graph horn in here
like this can be named whatever Andrew's
about to name them
new spreads from the art book what
Amelia
where is the set is this on Amazon or
somewhere Bruce
uh you know we've we've created this
really nice space and and uh you can get
additional vivariums correct uh it's a
different kind of Aesthetics and looks
to where you're keeping your beasts and
caring for them different Aesthetics
different vivariums with different
aesthetic looks for where you're keeping
your Beast it's a big part of this one
let me listen to that again make sure
that's what he said it's uh it's a
different kind of
Aesthetics and looks to where you're
keeping your beasts and caring for them
okay organ is a big part of the space as
well so as you progress through the
story you will unlock more
so as you can see this quite Meadow
themed um
right Nico just sent it to me say like a
swamp pull them up here in a second and
it's really really a visual effect to
and more space for for your feet oh wait
that's a large tree something about
Woodland
uh a large tree to add to the perfect
Woodland Retreat I think I might have to
name them after you guys
TG I think I might have to name them
after you all
we'll name them after people in the live
streams that'll be fun
and more space for for you Mr Moe what's
up dude welcome for when we're inside
the room requirement there's like on the
left there's that moon glow from one
entrance and then some of the mods first
so what are you talking about that's
exactly it ah oh you put trees in here
too oh my goodness
and and another thing with the the Beast
care that I think is is great uh you
know tying back to this same kind of
thing that you did with like the broom
where the broom is not just a method of
travel it's it's actually built in and
integrated right right in the same way
and look what are the limitations of
this area like obviously I don't think
you're just gonna be able to walk off
like I feel like right here is where it
kind of cuts off okay like Beast care
isn't just this this added element
you're not just throwing it on top
there's really this like narrative and
integration and then we can gather
moonstones here
how in the world does that work I don't
even want to think about the lore and
the magic involved in that
how did these items get here
everything everything so as you progress
through the missions you'll expand the
space
um as you earn resources you'll go into
Hogs Nico the needles it does it doesn't
unlock the gameplay here and unlock new
conjurations and different things to
play around with in the open world uh
it's in those different
um in those different environments
nippleton the third Netflix and
bandicamps and different things like
that that exist in the Overland those
things are what hold recipes that exist
in the loom blow the moon oh here we go
here we go stone that you find out in
the world is the resource that we use to
conjure everything that's found
throughout the world forageables are
used for recipes so he said that's found
throughout the world but we just found
some right in here
what if this is actually like the
vivariums are actually like teleporting
you to an actual physical space
somewhere
because like in my head
I mean isn't that how you guys have
imagined it like in your head like
that's all within the room of
requirement
but maybe because they did if you notice
when they transitioned into that it was
like it looked like they kind of cut
that transition like we didn't actually
see what'll be in the final game
so maybe that's actually like
teleporting us to an to a physical
location somewhere really everything's
like a everything's like a cycle and
keeps you coming back but even with the
story that's being told too it's not the
real world that's why it's a safe place
and uh yeah true particular affinity for
beasts yeah I mean it's just weird that
like these materials are here then
venturing out into the world uh and and
this is just kind of the tip of the
iceberg even even of kind of like your
interactions with beasts and that
narrative
listen to that again hold up
and and this is just kind of the tip of
the iceberg even even of kind of like
your interactions with me tip of the
iceberg
even with your interactions with the
Beast this is the tip of the iceberg so
you know what they're more they're more
uh kind of mysteries to discover and
things to discover around the world that
have to do with her and that have to do
with caring for peace dragon writing
Allen dragon writing uh uh that just
kind of can make this all come on coming
from the beginning the beginning of your
journey what well we could spend hours
in this is the beginning of the journey
to end the stream now we could spend
hours talking about this on live streams
as well Chandler
this is I'm just so blown away by how
like the combat are we gonna
I think Chandler says one more thing
about iceberg and that's just the tip of
the iceberg weird got more for you to
discover and find on your own thank you
for so much for being oh and you know we
will thank you for watching Hogwarts
Legacy is available for pre-order now it
releases you already know we will all
right Chad I'm glad we were finally able
to uh
to get through all that together
I I feel the same way Psalm I feel the
same way
at first I thought like I had a vision
of what obviously you have your hopes of
like oh you know it would be awesome if
it could grow if it could be this
and then you have your expectations
oh my goodness when was this posted
1 18 p.m this afternoon
thank you Nico thank you for shooting
that my way
Hogwarts Legacy art book offers
magically detailed look inside Potter
video game by the way if you guys are in
the US and have this pre-ordered I just
um I got a release date email the other
day I meant to tweet about it and forgot
but yeah they sent out an update for
release dates
I think it comes out like a week after
the game or something like that uh can't
make it to the Wizarding World of Harry
Potter theme parks
Hogwarts Legacy
looks like a lot of stuff we already
know 252
252 pages
oh wait this is so they got quotes and
everything here hold up hold up hold up
who all I had a really busy day at work
today so I haven't if this has been on
the Reddit stuff I haven't seen any up
through all the days of working on this
more and more incredible artwork would
arrive for us to see characters would be
refined and settings would be developed
it was a very exciting experience uh
revinson who is no stranger to Feeling
by the curtain of The Wizarding World
tells sci-fi wire oh and by the way
we've got an exclusive sneak peek inside
the Wonders publication which is rich in
original illustrations the covered art
included
wait where do they give the first name
of this uh
here we go
was written by Jody revinson and Michael
Owen both of whom got a front row seat
to the games ever evolving development
process dude
I'm definitely a wait why does it do
that come on
I'm definitely a detailed geek with the
philosophy that everything is important
to the story even the bathrooms for
Evanston adds there's such cleverness in
the names of the small towns and the
residents their merchandise and
backstories how could these not be
included learning all about the
professors of the time their
relationships and their personalities is
so important to your time at Hogwarts
same with your fellow students in the
beasts you encounter dude I bet all of
these character cards and stuff we've
been getting are like a precursor to
a preview of what we're going to be
getting in the actual in this book man
can we not blow this up here
okay let's open image a new tab oh all
right we'll zoom in though
all right so we have a nice little shot
of hogsmeat here
I think that's the three broomsticks you
got honeydukes over here
uh Jody Robinson Michael Owen pardon me
thank you
um
this is awesome
get the Sorting Hat here so chapter one
the first mission wait hold on is this
spoilery
hold on I'm scanning it really quick
okay no I think we're good I think we're
good I think we're good just want to
make sure the first mission
ancient magic page 20 a Wizard's Field
Guide page 22 chapter 2 where our story
starts the player's choices
oh
dude
80.
page 80 the Player's Choice is
cinematics bringing the story to life
chapter 3 establishing the locations the
room of requirement traversing the
highlands extracurricular activities
guys
activities plural yes they've said no
quidditch no gobstones no Wizards chest
but
there will be extracurricular activities
that's good that's good which we knew we
knew there was going to be some stuff
has to be chapter four The Beast of
Hogwarts Legacy 190 animating the Beast
is on page 214
chapter 5 golden paths and dark
Mysteries playing your way see dude
again they're like hammering on this
idea of of choosing your path but yet
they're like there's no moral
moral uh system or whatever
um casting a spell and then oh
page 250 continue play
continue play
what I mean we knew it had to be there
right we knew it had to be there
and it's only two pages
I know either right I had the same
reaction what continue it's only two
pages though so whatever it is is it's
very brief
very brief
but of course we're gonna be able to
keep playing like after
yeah how will they work that in
lore-wise like will they just freeze it
on a day and be like
you know the students just continue
acting like it's a normal school year
or what if it's like everybody's gone
for the summer and the Castle's just
like everybody's out of the castle
except a couple couple people
I don't think during summer break no
it's crazy as awesome as that would be
they're probably just gonna a lot of us
have predicted like maybe they freeze it
at the last
like before the final mission or
something
I mean like seeing how I don't want to
spoil the most recent God of War but
even even the 2018 God of War like games
are getting so much they're getting
better and better at how they handle
that like I this most recent God of War
Game Ragnarok I don't think I've ever
had a game that I immediately like beat
the main stuff to where I just
immediately there's like some pretty fun
story things
some pretty fun story things to go and
explore
that I'm like so anxious to do Zach
Donato what is up my friend
thank you so much for the five dollar
Super Chat did you hear that tip of the
iceberg Titanic confirm for the game no
the iceberg
the iceberg is on the way Zach thank you
so much for being here and I appreciate
your support my friend
oh dude this is super exciting though
let's see is there anything else oh my
oh my goodness there's a lot more okay
okay okay okay
there's a lot more
how has no one did did James have people
been tweeting about this all afternoon
and I've just missed all of it
all right let's see okay we've we've
seen a shot of the bat of the prefix
bathroom not from this angle
restful rooms bathrooms are a rather
newfangled concept for our era explains
Madison okay that's Boston Madsen
they're exciting new technology so this
is something students are likely to
write home about
to make their parents or great aunts and
uncles jealous of the upgrade great
pride is taken in some of hogwarts's new
plumbing and the bathrooms tend to be
some of the newest nicest looking areas
in the school what would one day be
moaning Myrtle's bathroom
and it's boys room counterpart is
probably the newest lavatory in the
school
like is that like
wait hold on that's like a urinal right
that's like a urinal isn't it
oh my goodness I love it dude okay wait
opposite top prefect Mermaid by Vanessa
Palmer
opposite bottom okay that's prefect
bathroom in-game render by the
environment team
the right bathroom door knob and a
Ravenclaw toilet
for or I think it says Buy
and then the bottom is Moaning Myrtle
bathroom in-game render
dude that's so good
yeah yeah so if you guys are just uh
I see we have some people asking what
this is yeah first I've seen of it too
Jenny whoever was the first person that
commented on that thank you thank you
for sending this our way I had not seen
this at all
hadn't seen anyone tweeting about it I'm
obviously gonna post about it here
shortly after we finish the stream but I
mean man this might be honestly this
might be worth me making a video over we
haven't even gotten to the last one yet
here
all right so this is the last one
an amazing shot of honeydukes right here
amazing shot of honeydukes honeydukes
sweet shops is a major meeting place in
the town overrun with fizzing wisbees
and chocolate frogs
there's the chocolate frogs dude
okay wait wait wait wait though wait
do they have wizard cards or not
do they have wizard cards or not okay
regulars of the stream you guys have
been through this with me if we've had
this whole
conversation about the lore of the
chocolate frogs
when people first started talking about
late 1800s there was a lot of
conversation about well chocolate frogs
wouldn't have been there yet because
there is this random
frame kid you not a frame in one of the
Fantastic Beast movies where it talks
about new chocolate frog Packaging
but I feel like there's wiggle room
there I feel like there's wiggle room
they talk about new chocolate frog card
Packaging
dude if chocolate frogs are in the game
I I want to collect the wizard cards
but a lot of people think that shot from
um the Fantastic Beasts movies is
basically them saying like
the whole idea of adding in a wizard
card was part of the new packaging which
makes sense
which makes sense but yeah what the heck
then you've got pumpkin juice right here
um let's see oh wait I didn't even
finish reading it's run by Patrick
Redding with his daughter Olivia
hopefully we get to meet them in game so
we got Patrick Redding and daughter
Olivia Redding I wonder if Olivia is
like
as she graduated from Hogwarts or is she
too young and hasn't started Hogwarts
yet
all right then we have top spread
honeydukes early concept by West Studio
man I'm really squinting to read these
guys opposite honeydukes sign design by
Dan simmonsson or Simpson then you have
chocolate frogs and then the left uh
fizzing wisby's candy pumpkin fizz drink
is what they called it so maybe they
didn't call it pumpkin juice at this
time and then a strudel pastry right
here
oh dude this is so fun
I mean just think we're gonna be able to
walk through we're gonna be able to walk
through these shops right here
walk through these shops I mean Zoom to
read it better but it's it's low res Mr
Moe it's low res
so it's gonna be blurry either way
now maybe if I can download uh
see if they have some better
they probably don't because they want
you to go to the site and look at them
foreign
more quotes here though the most fun was
getting to know the new characters and
exploring the new environments within
the missions Robinson explains I liked
hanging out with the students and most
of the professors and encountering new
magic the most challenging was when
those characters were revised or those
environments appeared or disappeared but
change is inevitable whether it was the
game itself or writing about the game
and so we just kept to our mission of
making sure the book was the best it
could be so I wonder if they did like
change because in another shot
oh man hold on how much time do we have
we don't we don't have enough time for
this we don't have enough time for this
kind of Deep dive
we don't have enough time
but in
one of the showcases I can't remember if
it was James or Ben
where they go over I think it was James
where they go to the table and you see
what looks like a chocolate frog card
but it was a different color not a
chocolate frog card I'm sorry
chocolate frog packaging but it was a it
was like a lightish blue color
and so some of us were speculating maybe
they changed it to like fit with that
whole fantastic Beast thing about the
lore
ah and so maybe that was something they
didn't get to change or maybe it is I
have no I have no idea I have no idea
while the authors understandably
hesitant uh let's see did we read that
one yet no we didn't we didn't
um she does promise that the new
characters and environments encountered
in Hogwarts Legacy fit perfectly into
the history we know and the feature we
know will be one of the most important
aspects of any time spent in The
Wizarding World Is Discovery and Anyone
who reads the book is going to discover
how the game was well thought out oh
let's go we already know it was well
thought out but
are the making of Hogwarts Legacy goes
on sale February 10th same day the game
arrives on PlayStation 5.
and then there's that one you can get a
really good
high-res shot of that one
see if we open it yeah see this one you
can zoom in a little bit on
showcase one yeah that's right that's
right
Zach
I'd be excited too trust me but yeah not
not happening
it's not happening guys I don't know I
don't know why
I would have loved to do it but
no showcase to Retro
so yeah if you guys just tuned in though
um again I don't know who sent it Nico
probably somebody probably caught it who
who actually posted this first I had not
seen this I'm not seeing this at all so
I'm gonna tweet this right now
um
to get this out there
doing at Hogwarts Legacy stop it
stop it Twitter
all right uh just
came across this
okay what is uh sci-fi
sci-fi wire
with a sneak peek
at the the art and making of
Hogwarts Legacy
this book is going to be so fun
for fans to go through after launch
check for typos
since I can't edit my tweets
boom
I know dude
it's gonna be so fun to go through that
book Because at first I was like 45
dollars
or an art book
shouldn't this have been in the
collector's edition
maybe so but it definitely looks like
it's gonna be a book that is uh packed
with detail I mean what did they say
here 252 pages
yeah
which by the way I want to pull up my uh
so here's the here's the shot of
honeydukes guys for any of you who just
are jumping in
table of contents talks about continue
play nons I would say non-spoilers on
that stuff none of that is like too
crazy
get a nice overview of the bathrooms
here and then the shot of honeydukes I
love it man I love it
but I do want to pull up I want to see
what my email said because I just got an
email
her uh let's see art and making
it's not gonna arrive on
launch day for me so I'm in the US I
pre-ordered it on Amazon it it says mine
is expected to deliver on Thursday
February 16th this is for the art book
yo have a good one elwin thank you for
being here
oh when you don't elwin come on now you
don't have to apologize for leaving
early you were here like so much for
some the vast majority of streams
all good all good
have a good one Owen
that is that is very true Kelly that is
very true
try to be careful with my words on that
because I don't want to make WB really
mad at me but but I'm just like come on
man
come on
yeah so my uh art and making says it's
gonna deliver the 16th and Amazon lists
the Amazon says release date February
14th but that could just be an Amazon
thing this article here said it's going
to release the same day as the game
February 10th maybe that's like actually
in bookstores or something
so we shall see we shall see
Amazon Canada February 14 too gotcha
Jenny yeah that's mine
that's same for us
Jake I should comment on your comment I
just did
on Twitter you mean
I'll take a look later I'll take a look
all right guys so we have hit a crazy
ridiculous number of likes
crazy with the ridiculous number of
likes from all you guys today so
oh Lauren why are you got why are you
lying to us I mean I'm not
I truly mean when I say I would I would
never straight up lie to you guys if I
had filmed a showcase
I just wouldn't talk about it I'd be
like so cagey think about it I wouldn't
talk this freely
I wouldn't talk this freely like no of
course I'm not
I would not talk to freely I would just
ignore all the questions about it
but ignore all of him I do I really do
wonder if there's a third I have no idea
if there is like you would think 100
it's already been filmed
100 it's already been filmed and they do
have enough time like they definitely
have enough enough time to release
another one
because we got a month left
so you you think ASMR in there somewhere
winter ASMR
possibly depending on if they send out
early review copies or preview copy like
whatever they do on that front that will
be in the lead up to Launch
and then if they did another showcase
and or trailer Maybe
there's definitely enough time for that
but I feel like a lot of that would have
already had to have been made and like
ready to go
T-minus 26 more days
with D6 more days
do you avoid spoilers until April should
you see everything
oh gosh Hillary that's tough
that's tough
I mean for me personally if it were me
but you I mean you guys do what you want
to do right I'm not you do what you want
to do personally if it were me
I would I wouldn't care about
story spoilers which I know a lot of
people be like what that'd be the main
thing I'd care about
I I actually when I play games like I
want to solve things and I want to
figure out a lot of the things on my own
so I may watch like the first few hours
of the game I may watch people doing
like free roam stuff but I don't think I
would want to watch the whole thing like
I wouldn't want to know how to solve
every single thing
going in story stuff I would be less
worried about now if it was a book or
movie of course I don't want to be
spoiled on it but on the on the story
that could just be me
in my Amazon cart along with a strategy
guide same Roger same and I don't even
normally do strategy guides but I'm like
this could come in handy for making
videos
this could come in very handy
foreign
NBA oh I know it was a typo in D.A
yeah exactly Mr Mo yeah I've talked
about it on stream we actually unboxed
the God of War Ragnarok
collector's edition not even the yotinar
yeah we talked we talked about it quite
a bit on here
we talked about it quite a bit
foreign
see the intro you think nice
uh they've they've confirmed that David
yes yes yes that's confirmed you can see
that in the Showcase they walk up to the
little Pub
in the little uh like the Little Village
area you see the character and then
we've seen them drink tea before I don't
know if we've seen them eat anything but
I you gotta think there would be
something they would be able to like
snack on at some point
all right guys we hit like I said we hit
a crazy number of likes so it is time
for a bit of Random
Harry Potter quote trivia
Harry Potter quote trivia the way this
game works is I pick a random line from
the series
gosh Noob ten to four
Noob have a good night my friend thank
you for being here Hermione lots of
Hermione's lots of Hermione's book three
Oliver wood Sheamus Hermione Dean book
force is Brittany Ron book three dean
book three Ron book three Hermione book
three read George book four
oh Sheamus book three Jetty book four
Fred and George book two Jenny book four
dude somebody actually got it
and I think this person has gotten it
just about every week
so I don't know if they're doing a
little Googling nah Brittany wouldn't do
that Brittany wouldn't do that I think
Britney has a fantastic memory Brittany
you were correct it is Dean Thomas in
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire book
four
look for so it is uh let's see it's
McGonagall I'm pretty sure it's
McGonagall talking here I think they're
in Transfiguration
yeah you're now entering a most
important phase of your magical
education she told them her eyes
glinting dangerously behind her Square
spectacles your ordinary Wizarding
levels are drawing closer we don't take
owls till fifth year said Dean Thomas
indignantly there we go
good job good job nicely done two points
for Brittany
two points yo and Mr Mo with the ten
dollar Super Chat
thank you Mr Mo if you haven't done the
impression yet this is stream three
events
for Bellatrix I killed series by oh my
gosh and you you gave a super chat I
think we got to make it that one
I think you got to make it that one
I think I think we gotta go with it Mr
Mel
all right so hold on
let me look up the exact quote
actually you know what I want to get I'm
going to get the video
this is gonna be hard guys and I'm just
gonna tell you right now this one's not
gonna be good
this one's not gonna be good
all right I'm gonna mute the stream I'm
not gonna show it we don't want to get
any copyright issues here
all right let's see when does she start
screaming it
where is it where is it where is it
you coming to get me
oh dude okay
most I think so far we've done all male
voices I don't think we've done any
female voices yet let me listen to it
one more time I mean listen to it one
more time
[Music]
I think I can actually do the uh yeah
come on get me the other part though
oh my gosh okay
all right I'm gonna try it I'm gonna try
it you guys
this is what a ten dollar Super Chat
will get you
oh my goodness okay hold on let me get
wait hold on you know what dude
let's get in the in that dark wizard
mode
at dark wizard mode the other ones I
feel like have been solid my Snape
wasn't my best but I feel like Dobby is
pretty good
I could do a decent Hagrid olivander's
my best by far
foreign
yeah yeah
all right all right all right you guys
are giving me okay I'm feeling a little
confident
also
I can't do it that loud my son's bedroom
is literally it's not a cop-out my son's
bedroom is literally right above
it's right above this room here
this is gonna be so bad it's gonna be so
it's just cringe I can I could I I feel
I feel the cringe already I feel
I feel the cringe already okay hold on
hold on okay so she's like you know
she's doing this just it's just this
maniacal
she's she's jogging through almost like
skipping through
okay hold on I'm gonna back up back up I
can't get that I can't get that high
pitched I'll just tell you guys now can
I get my voice that high pitch
laughs
I killed I killed I killed
I killed Sirius Black
me Potter
there it is there it is that's the best
I got that's the best I could do man
I can't get my voice that high or as as
my voice literally cracks and breaks
oh dude
that was a lot
I don't know how to interpret that Nico
I don't know how to interpret interpret
that Dustin went in with low yeah that's
very important like I I wanted to set
the expectations very low Michael
Jackson
oh camo
oh we could do we could go Michael
Jackson I think I could do Michael
Jackson better than Bellatrix no it's
not happening in this stream
oh man elwyn's gonna be so mad at you
guys
elwyn's gonna be so mad because I'm
pretty sure Elwyn has requested
Bellatrix every single time
Dobby cosplaying
that might be so good pineapple Sam that
I have to try to do it right now
I'll be
Masters presented Dobby with clothes
okay Dobby and Bellatrix Dobby okay
master I killed serious Black
coming to get me Potter
I can't do oh my gosh I can't I just
Dobby serious black or no not serious
black Dobby Bellatrix Dobby tricks
so good dude
so good of a suggestion the impression I
know probably wasn't that great dark dog
Dobby Emo's in the chat Dobby laughing
emotes as well dude
oh man you got double A you guys got
double this week you got double
we did hit 300 though we did hit 300
likes and Mr Mo get a 10 super chat
so all right we I feel good I feel good
about the upgrade this week man
sounded the same to me was it too close
I love doing Dobby man
with clothes
Harry Potter has free Dolby
Dobby is free
you gotta get that little crack at the
end
I've heard that when so many dude if you
ever listen to the uh
Potter cast the official podcast of the
Leaky cauldron
they had a guy who did an impression of
that one time I think they actually had
an episode where people submitted
impressions
and they kept that one in they kept the
one they like used that in their outro
and so just like every outro Dopey is
free is so good man
oh just such an epic moment
don't be killed serious
oh man
Dobby and voltage
yo I'm pretty sure it wasn't the wasn't
the Laughing Voldemort ear idea Nico
oh yeah let's check our polls check our
Pole
I'm pretty sure that the uh laughing
Voldemort I mean several people
suggested it but I think that one
started with Nico
a heavy pre-order four percent
said no don't plan to those are the four
percent
like you're the real ones man you're the
real ones you must be such a fan of the
channel and the stream if you are here
hanging out in the live stream and
you're not
Legacy or you know what maybe you're
planning on buying it after I didn't
even think about that
I didn't even think about that like
maybe you're buying after launch
darn it that's the four percent twenty
percent waiting for impression 76
percent yes
have pre-order we had 764 votes let's go
man thank you guys for everyone who
voted in the poll
I did too Kelly I did pre-order twice
don't be Dolby didn't mean to kill
Sirius Black
did not mean for Harry Potter to be
angry with him
best 10 dollars I've ever spent foreign
Mr Moe I'm glad you feel that way man
glad you feel that way
going to very soon Mike says would like
to pre-order 48 more times
oh dude I guess technically
I was thinking about the ones we gave
away for the Christmas stream but
everybody fun fact so everybody who won
who participated in the Christmas live
stream we did we did uh for any of the
newcomers here we did a giveaway we gave
away three copies of Hogwarts Legacy
Deluxe
however all of them chose the
PlayStation versions and Playstation
doesn't support gifting so instead of
actually being able to gift them
Hogwarts Legacy I had to just give them
PSN credit which I mean it's kind of the
same thing but it's like maybe they did
pre maybe they bought something else
with it I don't know
just up to them right whatever they want
to do with it
yeah whoever clipped that I saw some
people saying they clipped it we got to
make sure Elwyn gets to see that so she
doesn't go crazy on you guys because I
know she is suggested Bellatrix every
week
she has suggested Bellatrix every week
and we didn't do it we didn't do it
you tagged her already Janine thank you
nice nice
yeah she'll see it there
all right guys yo I think it's gonna be
a man another great live stream right at
the three hour mark right at three hour
mark so like I said man if you all any
of you out there who love watching
gameplay streams I know some of you were
hanging out the other day when we did
Goblet of Fire but we are gonna try to
finish Goblet of Fire I'm definitely a
hundred percent I shouldn't say 100 99
barring sickness or illness within my
family or family emergencies I plan to
be streaming next Monday because I have
the whole day off work
um my wife is off work as well it'll be
a really good day to do some streaming
but I also want to try and do some
evening streams this week I really want
to try and get through Goblet of Fire
the console version of Goblet of Fire in
the next week so we can get moved on to
a much better game and order the Phoenix
which I already have I've got the PS3
copy I've got my PS3 ready to go I'll
set it up right here so we'll be doing
those over on Twitch and then I'll be
bringing over to YouTube so if you if
you just prefer to do YouTube You'll see
them over as let's plays on the channel
uh but yeah man thank you guys for being
here
yo Dustin as we close it out here Dustin
with the 20 Super Chat Dustin thank you
so much uh d d galleons d gallons
reminding everyone to stay hydrated
since noob's gone for the night Dustin
man thank you so much for the support
Dustin guys all all the super chats like
I I really do appreciate it I really do
appreciate it very much make sure you
always take care of yourself first
make sure you take care of yourself
first the people closest to you and then
if you choose to throw a little money my
way a little donation memberships all
that like
it it really does mean a lot thank you
all so much
anhydrate hydrate there from Dustin
which when we're on Twitch you can you
guys can do the little hydrate
just to add more more things like that
that you can do
nah it's not just for PS5 Northwest it's
also for PC and uh Xbox series X and S
yep
just to spend 20 to get you hydrated and
healthy I spend ten dollars to strain
your voice yeah like my kids screaming
he's awake now no I'm kidding I'm
kidding
if he wasn't if if it was like if he
wasn't there or if he wasn't awake if it
was like day if he wasn't awake if he if
he was awake
I would have gotten a lot louder
I would have gotten a lot louder because
she it's like kind of like echoing she's
running down the hall so I could have
almost like done it over there on the
other side
side of the room there
Moon Lily Moon Lily you missed so much
it's all good power outage where you
live oh no hopefully nothing too serious
well guys uh anyone who watches on the
replay let me know down in the comments
thank you all for being here
um again we had crazy number of likes
here replay Squad like the video as well
it's gonna help more people find the
live streams and I know we were joking
earlier about time stamps I really do
appreciate what you'll go and say like
when certain discussions happen so we
can go in and flag those and I can put
the chapters in so it's easier for
people to
to jump to the different spots so
that's all I got ma'am
it's getting like
man it's just so it's just crazy to
think like how few of We're not gonna
stop streaming even after Hogwarts
Legacy even when we move on to other
topics we're going to keep streaming
gonna do all kinds of big things here
but
but this is like a special moment in
time man only a few more of these left
of us not knowing what the game is like
you know of us not being able to play it
having it in our hands
guys you are the best man thank you all
for being here again I I I'm sorry I
don't remember the person's name who
initially sent this to me and and tipped
us off on this new article from sci-fi
here about the art book thank you very
much for doing that
um yeah that was a good that was a good
news story for us to cover I may have to
make a whole separate video on that so
um hope you all have a fantastic rest of
your week
and maybe I'll see you again soon maybe
I'll see you on Twitch this week uh
Discord exclamation point Discord if
you're not a member there you can also
follow me over on Twitter at retro
record tour anytime I'm going live
those are the best places to find out
as always
thank you all so much for watching
I will talk to you again soon
foreign